REPORT THEN -- SEVENTY I WANT TO
SAY THOSE WHO NEED TRANSLATION --
PLEASE GO TO THE FRONT CHECK IN
TABLE SO THAT YOU CAN RECEIVE A
HEADSET.
SO AS WE'RE HAVING OUR
CONVERSATION YOU CAN -- IN
SHOULD MAKE SURE THAT YOU'RE
RECEIVING THE NECESSARY
INFORMATION THERE MAY BE TIMES.
WHEN WE MAY I MAY SPEAK IN
SPANISH AND THEY'RE ALSO
HEADSETS FOR YOU IF YOU WANT?
TO HAVE THAT TRANSLATED BUT I'LL
MAKE SURE THAT WE DO THE TOOL --
TRANSLATION TO MAKE SURE THAT NO
ONE GETS LEFT OUT OF THE
CONVERSATION THANK YOU.
FIRST OF ALL I'D LIKE TO SAY
GOOD EVENING AND THANK YOU
EVERYONE FOR PARTICIPATING IN
THIS HEARING.
OF THESE ASSEMBLY SELECT
COMMITTEE ON INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
I WANT TO THANK YOUR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MY ESTEEMED COLLEAGUE
EDUARDO GARCIA FOR INVITING US
TO HOLD THIS HEARING HEARING
COULD TELL.
AND A BIG THANK YOU TO HIS STAFF
FOR THE FINE JOB HELPING SET
THIS UP AND I WANTED VERY MUCH
THANK THEM LOOK AT THIS TURNOUT.
THIS HEARING IS BEING LIVE
STREAMED TO THE SELECT
COMMITTEES PAGE ON THE STATE
ASSEMBLY'S WEBSITE AND TO MY
LEGISLATIVE FACEBOOK PAGE YOU
CAN ALSO LIKE ME ON FACEBOOK AS
MUCH AS YOU LIKE HIM.
VIDEO OF THE ENTIRE HEARING WILL
BE ARCHIVED TO LINK THAT THE
SELECT COMMITTEE PAGE WITH
CLOSED CAPTIONING.
VIDEO OF OUR MOST PREVIOUS
HEARINGS ARE ARCHIVED IT'S LIKE
COMMITTEES PAGE AS WELL FOR
FUTURE HEARINGS AS WELL AS
FUTURE TERMS WILL BE.
NOW LET'S GET TO THIS HEARING.
I'M ASSEMBLY MEMBER JIM FRAZIER
I AM THE CHAIR OF THE ASSEMBLY.
SELECT COMMITTEE ON ON
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITIES.
I REPRESENT THE ELEVENTH
ASSEMBLY DISTRICT.
IT'S THE DELTA REGION IN
CALIFORNIA.
I'M HERE TODAY BECAUSE I CHAIR
OF THIS COMMITTEE AND HELPING
THE ID DE COMMUNITY.
IT SUPPORTED DESERTS FROM THE
STATE IS A PASSION FOR ME AND
ALSO MY COLLEAGUE.
BUT THIS HEARING IS NOT ABOUT ME
OR MY CALLING.
WE ARE HERE TO LISTEN TO YOU.
WE'RE HERE TO DISCUSS THE
CHALLENGES FACED BY FAMILIES WHO
LIVE WITH INTELLECTUAL AND
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES.
I DID THE AFFECTS ALL OF US
REGARDLESS OF OUR BACKGROUND.
OR WHERE WE LIVE.
R. IDG POPULATION CONTINUES TO
GROW.
AND WE MUST PROVIDE ESSENTIAL
SERVICES AND SUPPORT TO ARE IDG
FRIENDS NEIGHBORS AND OUR FAMILY
MEMBERS.
AT THE CAPITOL WE DON'T HEAR
FROM YOU MUCH.
AND NOT AS MUCH AS WE'D LIKE TO
SO WE BROUGHT THE COMMITTEE TO
YOU.
WHAT COMMITTEES ARE DIFFERENT
FROM STANDING LEGISLATIVE
COMMITTEES?
WE DON'T HOLD HEARINGS ON
PENDING LEGISLATION.
BUT LEGISLATION IN HAPPENED WITH
YOUR INPUT.
WE LEARNED FROM PREVIOUS
HEARINGS.
THAT LISTENING TO YOUR STORIES
IS THE MOST VALUABLE THING WE'RE
GOING TO DO TONIGHT.
WE HAVE SET ASIDE AMPLE TIME AT
THE END OF THE HEARING FOR
PUBLIC COMMENT TO HEAR FROM YOU
ALSO.
WE DO HAVE A FULL AGENDA SO
LET'S GET STARTED.
WE WILL BEGIN WITH PRESENTATIONS
BY THE INLAND REGIONAL CENTER
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR LEVINE A
JOHNSON.
AN ASSOCIATE TO GET EXACTED
RECORD KEVIN -- LEVINE AND KEVIN
IS SO GOOD TO SEE YOU AGAIN.
PLEASE START OUR HEARING TODAY
IT'S GOOD TO SEE YOU TOO AND
IT'S GOOD TO MEET YOU.
ASSEMBLYMAN GARCIA.
GOOD EVENING ASSEMBLYMAN FRAZIER
AND ASSEMBLYMAN GARCIA CONSUMERS
FAMILIES ADVOCATES AN I. R. C.
VENDORS.
THANK YOU FOR INVITING IN THE
REGIONAL CENTER TO THE COACHELLA
PUBLIC HEARING.
WE APPRECIATE THAT YOU ARE
WILLING TO LISTEN TO AND THEN
REGIONAL CENTER AND THE FEEDBACK
FROM YOUR COMMUNITY.
WE ARE HOPEFUL THAT THE INPUT WE
HERE THIS EVENING WILL ASSIST
OUR AGENCY TO IMPROVE
RELATIONSHIPS AND SERVICES FOR
THOSE WE SERVE.
MY NAME IS LIVING A JOHNSON I AM
THE EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR OF INLAND
REGIONAL CENTER WITH ME THIS
EVENING IS KEVIN EARTH ASSOCIATE
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR DIRECTOR AND
IN THE AUDIENCE.
PLEASE STAND WHEN I CALL YOUR
NAME.
WE HAVE CAMERON PAGE OR BOARD
VICE CHAIR.
ELIZABETH TAGAL PROGRAM MANAGER
RIVERSIDE TRANSITION.
LEE AND PEERS PROGRAM MANAGER
RIVERSIDE SCHOOL AGE EAST.
ERIC CAM MILLER.
PROGRAM MANAGER RESEARCH AND
DEVELOPMENT.
LILIANA GANIC A CULTURAL
DIVERSITY SPECIALIST.
EDU BURDICK AND BETH CRANE
CONSUMER EMPLOYMENT SPECIALIST
AND JONATHAN AT BRIDGE PROGRAM
MANAGER TRAINING.
THESE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO MAY BE
ABLE TO ANSWER YOUR QUESTIONS OR
REFER YOU TO SOMEONE WHO CAN.
PLEASE FEEL FREE TO INTRODUCE
OURSELVES TO THEM.
I HAVE BEEN SERVING IN THE
REGIONAL CENTER CONSUMERS FOR
THE PAST THIRTY YEARS.
I STARTED A SERVICE COORDINATOR
IN NINETEEN EIGHTY EIGHT AND
EVENTUALLY ROSE TO MY CURRENT
POSITION IN TWO THOUSAND AND
FIFTEEN I AM ALSO THE
GRANDMOTHER OF A TWENTY ONE YEAR
OLD YOUNG MAN WITH CEREBRAL
PALSY.
LIKE SOME FAMILIES HERE THIS
EVENING I HAVE EXPERIENCED THE
STRUGGLES AND THE JOYS OF HAVING
A FAMILY MEMBER WITH A
DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITY.
WITH MY DAUGHTER AT THE HELM WE
HAVE BEEN STRONG ADVOCATES FOR
HIS MEDICAL AND EDUCATIONAL
NEEDS.
IT HAD BEEN DIFFICULT AT TIMES
YET WE REMAIN STRONG AS A TEAM
IN ORDER TO INSURE THAT HE
RECEIVED THE SERVICES HE NEEDS
TO BE AN INDEPENDENT MEMBER OF
HIS COMMUNITY.
I AM VERY WHERE I AM VERY AWARE
OF THE STRENGTHS AND WEAKNESSES
OF THE AGENCY AND MY PURPOSE
THIS EVENING.
IS TO PROVIDE YOU WITH
INFORMATION TO CLARIFY WHY SOME
OF THE CURRENT ISSUES REMAIN A
CHALLENGE.
IN THE REGIONAL CENTER HAS GAPS
IN ITS SERVICE PROVISIONS
PARTICULARLY IN THE COACHELLA
VALLEY AND WE ARE DEDICATED TO
ADDRESSING THOSE GAPS.
I WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES WE FACE IN
ACCOMPLISHING THAT GOAL AND
WELCOME THE FEEDBACK FROM THE
COMMUNITY AND HELPING US
IDENTIFY AND ADDRESS OUR
PRIORITIES.
IN THE REGIONAL CENTER CURRENTLY
EMPLOYS SEVEN HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE STAFF OF HIM FIVE
COORDINATORS.
WE ARE A LARGE AGENCY COVERING
TO COUNTIES AND OUR STRUCTURE
REFLECTS THIS.
WE HAVE A LARGE SPECIALIZED
UNITS WHICH CONSIST OF THE
FEDERAL MEDICAID WAIVER PROGRAM.
LEGAL INTAKE AND CLINICS.
ON A MONTHLY BASIS OUR INTAKE
UNIT PROCESSES AN AVERAGE OF
THREE HUNDRED INDIVIDUALS WHO
MAY BE FOUND ELIGIBLE OR
TRANSFER IN FROM OTHER REGIONAL
CENTERS.
THIS DATA REFLECTS THE CURRENT
DEVELOPMENT OF HOMES AND
BUSINESSES IN THE INLAND EMPIRE.
ARE GROWING POPULATION IS
CURRENTLY AT THIRTY EIGHT
THOUSAND SIX HUNDRED AND FORTY
SEVEN CONSUMERS.
WE HAVE MANY NEW EMPLOYEES BUT
UNFORTUNATELY IT TAKES TIME FOR
THESE EMPLOYEES TO LEARN WHO
THEIR CONSUMERS ARE WHAT THEIR
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE AND WHAT
RESOURCES ARE AVAILABLE TO THEM.
WE REALIZE THAT REASSIGNING
CONSUMERS TO NEW AND DIFFERENT
CASE MANAGER THIS FRUSTRATING
FOR FAMILIES AND THAT GETTING TO
KNOW THEM CAN'T TAKE TIME.
BUT IT IS THE ONLY WAY WE CAN
ADDRESS SUCH GROWTH.
I RC IS THE LARGEST OF THE
REGIONAL CENTERS BOTH IN
GEOGRAPHIC AREA AND NUMBER OF
CONSUMERS SERVED.
I RC SERVER SAMBAR MEDINA AND
RIVERSIDE COUNTIES WHICH HAVE A
COMBINED AREA OF APPROXIMATELY
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND FOUR
HUNDRED SQUARE MILES AND A
COMBINED POPULATION OF OVER FOUR
POINT FIVE MILLION PEOPLE.
SERVING OUR POPULATION
GEOGRAPHIC AREA IS A SIGNIFICANT
CHALLENGE OR PERHAPS AN EVEN
GREATER CHALLENGE IS ADDRESSING
THE REGION'S GROWTH.
IN JULY OF TWO THOUSAND AND
FIFTEEN AND THEN REGIONAL CENTER
HAD APPROXIMATELY THIRTY
THOUSAND FOUR HUNDRED CONSUMERS.
WHICH MEANS WE ARE GROWING BY
MORE THAN TWO THOUSAND CONSUMERS
PER YEAR.
WE RECOGNIZE THAT OUR GROWTH HAS
OUTPACED OUR ABILITY TO DEVELOP
THE RESOURCES TO MEET THAT
GROWTH.
HOWEVER WE CONTINUE TO STRIVE TO
DO JUST THAT.
I MENTIONED EARLIER THAT WE ARE
ATTEMPTING TO ADDRESS OUR
SERVICE GAPS. TO DO THIS I RC
NEEDS TO BETTER FUND OUR CURRENT
PROVIDERS AND PROBABLY EVEN
BRING MORE SERVICE PROVIDERS
INTO OUR AREA.
HOWEVER THIS IS MORE DIFFICULT
THAN IT MAY SOUND.
MANY SERVICE PROVIDERS ARE
UNWILLING TO GO OUT INTO OUR
MORE DISTANT OR ISOLATED AREAS
SUCH AS THE COACHELLA VALLEY
WHERE THEY ARE MOST NEEDED.
ESPECIALLY FOR THE RATES THAT WE
CAN PROVIDE FOR THEIR SERVICE.
IN THE ASSEMBLY BUDGET COMMITTEE
NUMBER ONE ON HEALTH AND HUMAN
SERVICES AND AFTER PUBLIC
COMMENT ASSEMBLYMEMBER FRAZIER
YOU EXPRESSED CONCERN ABOUT
PUTTING ADDITIONAL WORKLOAD ON
ALREADY OVERTAXED REGIONAL
CENTERS.
PARTICULARLY CONSIDERING
EXISTING CASELOADS CASELOAD
RATIOS AND NON COMPLIANCE WITH
FEDERAL REQUIREMENTS.
ASSEMBLY FRAZIER YOU REPEATEDLY
NOTED CHALLENGES IN SERVING
INDIVIDUALS IN A SYSTEM THAT IS
UNDERFUNDED.
AND LACKING ENOUGH PROVIDERS TO
MEET EXISTING EXISTING NEEDS.
I WOULD LIKE TO TAKE THIS
OPPORTUNITY TO THANK YOU FOR
YOUR ONGOING EFFORT TO EDUCATE
YOURSELF AND THE ASSEMBLY ABOUT
THE NEEDS OF THE DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY COMMUNITY.
IT IS IMPORTANT FOR FAMILIES TO
UNDERSTAND HOW INLAND REGIONAL
CENTERS ELIGIBILITY PROCESS
WORKS.
REQUESTING AN INTAKE APPLICATION
IS THE FIRST STEP IN APPLYING
FOR SERVICES.
AN APPLICANT CAN DO SO BY EITHER
COMPLETING AN ONLINE
QUESTIONNAIRE OR BY CALLING OUR
INTAKE DEPARTMENT.
IF APPROPRIATE THE APPLICANT
WILL RECEIVE AN INTAKE PACKET
CONTAINING AN APPLICATION.
CONSENT FORMS AND ADDITIONAL
INFORMATION ABOUT ELIGIBILITY
AND REGIONAL CENTER PROCESSES.
REFERRALS ARE MADE BY PARENTS OR
LEGAL GUARDIANS OF APPLICANTS
UNDER AGE.
EIGHTEEN AN APPLICANT AGE
EIGHTEEN AND OLDER SHOULD REFER
THEMSELVES.
IF THE APPLICANT WOULD LIKE TO
HAVE A FAMILY MEMBER OR FRIEND
ASSIST THEM DURING THE PROCESS
THEY MUST FIRST GIVE CONSENT.
ONCE ELIGIBLE.
THE CONSUMER IS A FIND A SERVICE
COORDINATOR WHO WILL COME TO THE
CONSUMERS HOME AND DEVELOP THE
INDIVIDUAL PROGRAM PLAN ALSO
CALLED THE I. P. P..
THE I. P. P. IS THE PROCESS
WHERE THE FAMILY CONSUMER AND
SERVICE COORDINATOR EXPLORE
APPROPRIATE SERVICES.
SOME OF THE SERVICES MAY BE
REGIONAL CENTER FUNDED AND SOME
MAY BE GENERIC.
REGIONAL CENTERS ARE NOT DIRECT
SERVICE PROVIDERS WE CONTRACT
WITH VENDORS WHO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES SUCH AS RESPITE IN
BEHAVIOR MANAGEMENT.
THE SERVICE COORDINATOR ASSIST
THE CONSUMER TO OBTAIN SERVICES
AND TO HELP THE PERSON HELP
THEMSELVES.
AT THE I. P. P. THE CONSUMER AND
FAMILY DECIDE HOW OFTEN THEY
WANT TO HAVE ROUTINE CONTACT.
GENERALLY ANNUALLY SEMI ANNUALLY
AND QUARTERLY.
THE SERVICE COORDINATOR CAN
CONTACT YOU OR YOU MAY CONTACT
THEM AT ANY TIME TO DISCUSS ANY
QUESTIONS OR NEEDS THAT YOU MAY
HAVE.
THIS IS JUST A BRIEF OVERVIEW OF
WHO WE ARE.
AND I LOOK FORWARD TO HEARING
YOUR INPUT AND SUGGESTIONS.
KEVIN IS UP NEXT AND WE'LL
DISCUSS THE VARIOUS WE PET PLACE
THANK YOU.
GOOD EVENING MY NAME IS KEVIN
ARTS ON THE ASSOCIATE EXECUTIVE
DIRECTOR IN ONE REGIONAL CENTER.
AND I'VE BEEN AT THE CENTER FOR
TWENTY EIGHT YEARS AND I TO
STARTED HIS CASE MANAGER.
I WOULD LIKE TO JOIN THE MINION
THANKING YOU FOR COMING OUT
TONIGHT TO LISTEN TO THE INPUT
FROM FROM THE COMMUNITY.
WE ARE AWARE THAT WE HAVE GAPS
IN OUR SERVICE PROVISION AND ARE
DEDICATED TO ADDRESSING THOSE
GAPS IN THE FUTURE.
I WOULD LIKE TO ADDRESS SOME OF
THE CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE IN
ACCOMPLISHING THAT GOAL.
THIS IS THE SECOND SUCH HEARING
HELD IN HIGHER SEIZE AREA AND WE
ARE ENCOURAGED THAT THE ASSEMBLY
RECOGNIZES THAT AN AREA AS LARGE
AS OURS.
HAS VERY DIVERSE NEEDS AND
ISSUES.
THE VINEYARD MENTIONED EARLIER
THAT WE ARE ATTEMPTING TO
ADDRESS OUR SERVICE GAPS. TO DO
THAT.
HIGHER SEED NEEDS TO BETTER FIND
OUR CURRENT PROVIDERS IN
PROBABLY BRING MORE SERVICE
PRIOR PROVIDERS INTO THE AREA.
LAVIGNE ALSO MENTION THAT MANY
SERVICE PROVIDERS ARE UNWILLING
TO GO OUT TO THE MORE DISTANT
ARE ISOLATED AREAS WHERE THEY
ARE MOST NEEDED.
BECAUSE OF THE INADEQUATE RATES
THAT WE'RE ALLOWED TO OFFER FOR
THEIR SERVICES.
I WOULD LIKE TO READ AN EXCERPT
FROM AN EMAIL FROM SEAT
EDUCATION INCORPORATED A
COMMUNITY INTEGRATION BEHAVIOR
MANAGEMENT AND STARK SUPPORTED
EMPLOYMENT SERVICE PROVIDER.
THAT WE HAVE ATTEMPTED TO BRING
INTO THIS AREA.
DEAR I RC AT ITS MEETING ON
JANUARY EIGHTH TWO THOUSAND
NINETEEN THE BOARD OF TRUSTEES
OF SEEK EDUCATION INCORPORATED.
CAREFULLY CONSIDERED I ARE SEIZE
PROPOSED FUNDING OF SEEKS
PROGRAMS.
HOWEVER THE PROPOSED REGIONAL
CENTER RATES FOR THE SERVICES
WERE FOUND TO BE INSUFFICIENT
AND UNSUSTAINABLE TO ENSURE THE
QUALITY OF CARE FOR THE
CONSUMERS.
THIS DECISION IS NOT OF COURSE A
REFLECTION OF VIRUSES VALUES AND
DEDICATION TO THE COMMUNITY.
IT ONLY INDICATES THE SCOPE OF
THE RESOURCES REQUIRED TO MEET.
THE CHALLENGING NEEDS OF THE
CONSUMERS.
SEEK EDUCATION RECEIVE SUPPORT
FROM OTHER REGIONAL CENTERS TO
DELIVER EFFECTIVE AND HIGH
QUALITY PROGRAMS.
THE PROPOSED REDUCED RATE HAS
LED TO A DIFFICULT DECISION OF
COMPROMISING THE INTEGRITY OF
THE PROGRAM.
A POSITION THAT WOULD BE AN
APPLICABLE AND COUNTERPRODUCTIVE
TO ADDRESS THE VERY CHALLENGE
THAT INITIALLY BROUGHT US
TOGETHER.
AND THE END OF THIS.
TOGETHER ON THIS ENDEAVOR AND
QUOTE.
WE REALIZE I RC WE REALIZE WE
HAD I RC REALIZE THAT WE HAVE
DIVERSE POPULATION OF CONSUMERS
OR UNDERSERVED OR UNSERVED.
AGAIN WE ARE MAKING EFFORTS TO
CHANGE THIS.
HOWEVER REACHING OUT TO
UNDERSERVED CONSUMERS AND
RETHINKING OUR SERVICE DESIGNS
WILL COME AT A COST.
HIGHER SEAT IS NOT COMPLETE ITS
FISCAL YEAR WITH THE PURCHASE OF
SERVICE SURPLUS WE SPEND ALL THE
MONEY THAT WE ARE ALLOCATED.
ACCORDING TO THE DDS DASHBOARD
FOUND ON THEIR WEBSITE THE
AVERAGE EXPENDITURE FOR
CONSUMERS OF ALL AGES STATEWIDE.
IS THIRTEEN THOUSAND THIRTY SIX
DOLLARS PER CONSUMER PER YEAR.
HOWEVER AND HIGHER SEIZE
CATCHMENT AREA THAT AMOUNT IS
ONLY TEN THOUSAND EIGHTY PER
CONSUMER PER YEAR.
WE ARE CERTAINLY NOT SAYING THAT
THE OTHER REGIONAL CENTERS ARE
OVER FUNDED WE REALIZE THEY HAVE
THEIR OWN SIGNIFICANT CHALLENGES.
HOWEVER WE DO HOPE THAT HIGHER
SEE MY SEE MORE COMPARABLE
DISTRIBUTION OF FUNDS IN THE
FUTURE.
I WOULD LIKE TO POINT OUT THAT
ALSO THAT IN THE COACHELLA
VALLEY WHERE WE HAVE TWO
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED AND FIVE
CONSUMERS.
WE SPENT TWO MILLION.
SIX HUNDRED NINETY EIGHT
THOUSAND DOLLARS OR TEN THOUSAND
SEVENTY SEVEN PER CONSUMER PER
YEAR.
THIS IS JUST THREE DOLLARS PER
YEAR LESS THAN WE SPEND PER
CONSUMER THROUGHOUT THE REST OF
OUR CATCHMENT AREA.
ANOTHER ISSUES THAT ARE EXISTING
SERVICE PROVIDERS ARE HAVING
GREAT DIFFICULTY HIRING STAFF
BECAUSE THE RATES HIGHER SEE IS
ALLOWED TO OFFER ARE SO LOW.
THEY SIMPLY CAN'T COMPETE WITH
OTHER INDUSTRIES.
IF WE DEVELOP MORE PROGRAMS ONE
MORE REASONABLE RATES AND WE
PROVIDE MORE SERVICES TO
UNSERVED OR UNDERSERVED DIVERSE
POPULATIONS ARE PER CAPITA
EXPENDITURES ARE SURE TO
INCREASE.
WITH THIRTY EIGHT THOUSAND
CONSUMERS AND GROWING IF WE JUST
WOULD NEED TO PURCHASE A SERVICE.
AUGMENTATION OF A HUNDRED AND
FOURTEEN MILLION.
HOWEVER EVEN RELATIVELY SMALL
CHANGES IMPLEMENTED AND VERY
LARGE REGIONAL CENTERS CAN HAVE
SIGNIFICANT FINANCIAL IMPACT.
FOR EXAMPLE ABOUT TWO YEARS AGO
THE THIRTY HOUR MONTH CAP ON
RESPITE WAS REMOVED.
WE WERE WE VERY MUCH A PLOT THAT
DECISION BUT AS A RESULT HIGHER
SEES ANYONE RESPITE EXPENDITURE.
FOR JUMPED FROM APPROXIMATELY
FIFTY TWO MILLION IN FISCAL YEAR
SIXTEEN SEVENTEEN TO
APPROXIMATELY SIXTY THREE
MILLION AND SEVENTEEN EIGHTEEN
AND IS NOW UP OVER EIGHTY FOUR
MILLION IN FISCAL YEAR.
EIGHTEEN NINETEEN THIS IS AN
INCREASE OF OVER THIRTY TWO
MILLION IN THE PAST TWO YEARS
AND RESPITE ALONE.
OUR SEIZE EFFORTS TO ADDRESS P.
O. S. DISPARITY HAVE PLAYED A
ROLE IN IN THIS RESULT SINCE
JANUARY FIRST OF TWENTY EIGHTEEN
THE NUMBER OF NEW AUTHORS
RESPITE AUTHORIZATIONS.
ERROR SEE IS.
FOUR THOUSAND NINETY EIGHT OF
THESE NEW REQUEST THREE THOUSAND
EIGHT ARE APPROXIMATELY 75% OR
FOR CONSUMERS WHO PREVIOUSLY
RECEIVED NO POS.
WE REALIZE WE HAVE GAS AND
DEFICIT CENTER SERVICE PROJECT
PROVISION AND ARE WELL AND
WELCOME THE FEEDBACK FROM THE
COMMUNITY.
AND HELPING US IDENTIFY AND
ADDRESS THE PRIORITIES.
THIS IS ESPECIALLY TRUE IN MORE
RURAL AREAS WHERE IT IS
DIFFICULT TO TRACK SERVICE
SERVICE PROVIDERS.
I SHOULD NOTE THAT ONE OF THE
REASONS OUR RATES ARE SO LOW AS
THE TRADITIONALLY HIGHER SEE WAS
A VERY CONSERVATIVE EVEN CHEAP
REGIONAL CENTER.
THE RESULT IS THAT RATES
NEGOTIATED A DECADE OR TWO A OR
TWO AGO RELATIVELY LOW.
WHILE THIS MAY BE ADMIRABLE FROM
THE TAXPAYER PERSPECTIVE IT IS
HAD SERIOUS LONG TERM NEGATIVE
CONSEQUENCES FOR HIGHER C..
DESPITE OUR AIR SEIZE CURRENT
EFFORTS TO BE MORE USER FRIENDLY.
ELEVEN YEARS AGO WELL FOR
INSTITUTIONS COAT FORTY SIX
NINETY ONE WAS INSTITUTED AND
LIMITED HIGHER SEIZE ABILITY TO
OFFER RATES THAT EXCEEDED
EXISTENT EXISTING MEDIAN RATES.
THIS IS COUNTRY SIGNIFICANTLY
CONTRIBUTED TO THE STAGNATION
AND RESOURCE DEVELOPMENT IN OUR
AREA.
I'M SURE THAT YOU ARE AWARE THAT
THERE WAS A RECENT ATTEMPT BY
DDS AND A CONTRACTOR BURNS AND
ASSOCIATES TO LOOK AT RATE.
ADJUSTMENTS.
WE HAVE SUMMARISED OUR
OPPOSITION TO THE IMPLEMENTATION
OF THEIR RECOMMENDATIONS IN A
LETTER TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS
AND MARCH NINETEENTH.
AND IN A MEETING WITH HER ON
APRIL FIFTEENTH.
THERE ARE COPIES AVAILABLE FOR
IF YOU WISH TO REVIEW THEM.
WE DO SUPPORT THE 8% SHORT TERM
ACROSS THE BOARD INCREASE
PROPOSED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
FRAZIER AND HOLDEN.
AND WE ARE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF
THEIR EFFORTS TO PROPOSE THIS.
ALTHOUGH THE FOCUS OF THIS
DISCUSSION HAS BEEN THE NEED TO
AUGMENT SERVICE PROVIDER RATES
AND INCREASE OUR PURCHASES
SERVICE BUDGET.
WE WOULD ALSO ASK THAT YOU LOOK
AT AND CONSIDER THE METS
METHODOLOGY FOR FUNDING IRIS.
REGIONAL CENTER [INAUDIBLE]
OPERATIONS COST.
AS YOU KNOW HIGH STAFFING RATIOS
ARE PROBLEM PRETTY MUCH
THROUGHOUT THE REGIONAL CENTER
SYSTEM.
IN SOME REGIONAL CENTERS.
IN SOME REGIONAL CENTERS HAVING
ADEQUATE STAFFING MAY AMOUNT TO
REPLACING PEOPLE WHO LEAVE OR
HIRING OCCASIONAL GROWTH
POSITIONS.
HOWEVER AND I RC WERE GROWTH IS
TREMENDOUS WE NEED TO HIRE NOT
JUST FOR VACANCIES BUT ALSO TO
MEET THAT TREMENDOUS GROWTH.
THAT MEANS ADDITIONAL FURNITURE
EQUIPMENT TRAVEL AND MILEAGE
COSTS WHICH CURRENTLY EXCEED A
MILLION DOLLARS A YEAR.
AND EVENTUALLY MORE OFFICE SPACE
WE NEED GOOD KIND OF A COP.
IT HAPPENS ASIAN PACKAGE TO
ATTRACT QUALIFIED EMPLOYEES IN
TRADITIONAL FUNDING STRATEGIES.
THAT THE STATE USES ARE BOTH
ANTIQUATED AND INSUFFICIENT.
THE TERRORIST ATTACK IN DECEMBER
OF TWENTY FIFTEEN RESULT AN
ATTORNEY TO SIGNIFICANTLY
INCREASE OUR SECURITY COST YET
NONE OF THIS WAS CONSIDERED AN
ART BUDGET ALLOCATION.
IN FACT WE ACTUALLY RETURN ONE
POINT ABOUT. ONE POINT FOUR
MILLION IN RENTS.
AFTER WE HAVE LOST THE USE OF
OUR GOD RESOURCE CENTER --
CONFERENCE CENTER.
LIVING YOU MENTION THAT WE
CURRENTLY HAVE SEVEN HUNDRED AND
SEVENTY ONE EMPLOYEES. TWO YEARS
AGO THIS TIME WE HAD SEVEN
HUNDRED AND TWENTY IN OUR CASE
LAWS ARE EVEN HIGHER NOW THAN
THEY WERE THEN.
WE CURRENTLY NEED FIFTY THREE
MORE CSC'S PLUS SUPPORT STAFF
AND EQUIPMENT TO GET.
TO SEVENTY TO ONE I SHOULD ALSO
NOTE THAT MANY IN MANY INSTANCES
WHERE FUNDING FOR ONE POSITION
WHEN AN AGENCY OR SCIENCE HAS
SEVERAL.
IT IS A VERY INEQUITABLE
APPROACH.
FINALLY WE SOMETIMES RECEIVE FAB
FEEDBACK OF OUR LACK OF PRESENCE
IN THE COMMUNITY FOR INFORMATION
WE PUT TOGETHER A BRIEF SUMMARY
OF THE CONTACTS AND OUTREACH
EFFORTS WE HAVE MADE IN THE
COACHELLA.
VALLEY COMMUNITY IN THE PAST
COUPLE OF YEARS.
AND IT DOES LIST THE STAFF
PEOPLE OF AFFILIATED WITH THOSE
ARE REACH COPIES.
FINALLY BEFORE CONCLUDING I
WOULD LIKE TO BRIEFLY MENTION A
PROGRAM AFFILIATED WITH I RC
THAT HELPS CONSUMERS IN WAYS
THAT THE WOMEN ACT CANNOT
ACCOMMODATE.
ANOTHER WAY WAS STARTED IN
NINETEEN EIGHTY SIX BY A HANDFUL
OF I RC STAFF WITH THE GOAL OF
BRIDGING THE GAP BETWEEN HIGHER
SEE ALLOWED SERVICES.
AND OTHER A MEDIA TEMPORARY
SERVICES THE IRC COULD NOT FIND.
ANOTHER WAY WAS AND IS FUNDED BY
HIGHER SEE DON'T HIGHER SEE
STAFF DONATIONS FUNDRAISERS AN
INDIVIDUAL COMMUNITY DONATIONS.
IN THE PAST FOUR YEARS EIGHT
HUNDRED AND SIXTY SIX CONSUMERS
WERE SERVICE A HUNDRED AND SEVEN
OF THOSE LIVING IN THE COACHELLA
VALLEY.
THIS INCLUDES ONE TIME PAYMENTS
FOR RENT UTILITIES CLOTHING
BURIAL SPEND DENTAL WORK.
THE AVERAGE GRANT AMOUNT IS FOUR
HUNDRED DOLLARS AND AGAIN NONE
OF THIS FUNDING COMES THROUGH
THE STATE. TWO HUNDRED AND
THIRTEEN HIGHER SEE STAFF AND
BOARD MEMBERS DONATE
APPROXIMATELY TWENTY FIVE
THOUSAND FIVE HUNDRED DOLLARS
PER YEAR TO THIS BECAUSE THAT'S
AND 7% INCREASE FROM LAST YEAR.
ALSO ALTHOUGH THIS YEAR'S
ANOTHER WAY GOLF TOURNAMENT WAS
HELD INTO MACULA.
LAST YEAR'S TOURNAMENT AND NEXT
YEAR'S TOURNAMENT WILL BOTH BE
HELD IN THE COACHELLA VALLEY
COMMUNITY JEANERETTE THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
MR GARCIA YOU HAD SOME QUESTIONS
OF THE UP PANEL YES THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR BEING HERE AND I HE WAS
THE SOLE.
WANTING TO GET THIS STARTED THAT
I DIDN'T GIVE MISTER FRAZIER THE
APPROPRIATE WARM WELCOMING. TO
THE COACHELLA VALLEY THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE AND COMING OUT
HERE I WANT -- TO JUST
ACKNOWLEDGE I THINK ANY TIME --
YOU HAVE AN ORGANIZATION COME
BEFORE YOU AND BEGINS TO
CONVERSATION WITH AN
INTROSPECTIVE ANALYSIS OF WHERE
THEY'RE AT I I THINK IT'S
COMMENDABLE TO SAY THE LEAST --
YOU'VE BASICALLY OUTLINED A LOT
OF THE THINGS THAT I WANTED TO
ASK QUESTIONS ABOUT QUESTIONS
SUCH AS WHAT ARE THE CHALLENGES
THAT I ARTS HE SEES.
HERE IN THE COACHELLA AND
BLIGHTED AREA.
WHAT ARE THE PERCENTAGES OF --
CONSUMERS RIGHT THAT THAT COME
FROM THIS AREA IN COMPARISON --
TO THE OVERALL -- CONSUMERS THAT
YOU HAVE OUR CLIENTS -- AND I OR
SEEN SO YOU YOU WHO ACTUALLY
OUTLINED A NUMBER OF ANSWERS.
TO MY QUESTIONS KIND OF
PREEMPTIVE AND I APPRECIATE THAT
I DO WANT TO GET INTO THE
CONVERSATION ABOUT.
KIND OF YOUR STRATEGY MOVING
FORWARD YOU MENTION ABOUT
SERVICE PROVIDERS WHAT IS THAT
STRATEGY LOOK LIKE FOR I RC AS
IT RELATES TO MAKING SURE THAT
WE HAVE.
MORE PROVIDERS ON THE GROUND FOR
OUR CLIENTS AND CONSUMERS HERE
IN THE AREA AND MAYBE --
EXECUTIVE DIRECTOR YOU MAY BE
ABLE TO START THE CONVERSATION
ON THAT.
WELL UP ON ON AN ONGOING BASIS --
OUR AGENCY IS A RECRUITING --
HOME GROWN PROVIDERS AND A SOME
OF THE AREA IF THEY WANT TO COME
IN.
AND IT'S A GETTING A PERSON
ESTABLISHED IN THE AREA WITH AT
LEAST A NUMBER OF CONSUMERS. TO
BE ABLE TO STE SUSTAINED THAT
COMPANY -- AND THERE'S A LOT OF
FACTORS THAT COME INTO PLAY FOR
THAT.
BUT WE HAVE BEEN DEVELOPING IN
THIS AREA AND WE ARE AT THIS
TIME INVOLVED IN THE AFFORDABLE
HOUSING OUT HERE IN THIS AREA AS
WELL -- AND WE'LL BE GLAD -- TO
ME A PROVIDE MORE INFORMATION TO
YOU AND I BELIEVE WE DO HAVE
SOME LIST OF SOME PROVIDERS
THANK YOU.
AS IT RELATES TO THE RATES IN
THE REIMBURSEMENT THAT'S BEEN AN
ISSUE THAT OUR OFFICES HAD A
CONVERSATION WITH YOU BEFORE
WHAT WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE
MOVING FORWARD.
IN ORDER TO BE ABLE TO ATTRACT A
GREATER -- A PRESENCE OF A
PROVIDERS IN THE AREA FOR THE
CLASS.
I MEAN WE'RE NOT SURE WHAT THE
IMPACT OF THE RATE STUDIES OR
ANY THAT IS GOING TO MEAN -- BUT
THE FOR INSTANCE THE MEDIAN RATE
ISSUE IS A HUGE ISSUE FOR US
BECAUSE AS I EXPLAINED EARLIER
THAT.
IN THE PAST WE'VE HAD VERY LOW
RATES HERE.
IN NEGOTIATED VERY LOW RATES AND
THEN THEY ESSENTIALLY PUT A
FREEZE BACK ELEVEN YEARS AGO
THAT SAID THAT NO NEW RATES CAN
EXCEED THE MEDIAN.
SO UNTIL THAT IS IS CHANGING
EVEN WE PROBABLY BE CONTENT IF
THE IF WE WERE LIMITED TO THE
STATEWIDE MEDIAN AS OPPOSED TO
JUST OUR LOCAL MEDIA -- BECAUSE
YOU KNOW IN SOME CASES WE ARE
RATE IT DOESN'T ISN'T ENOUGH FOR
ON PEOPLE TO HIRE PEOPLE AT
MINIMUM WAGE MUCH LESS PAY
BENEFITS -- OR HAVE THEIR OWN
OVERHEAD COVERAGE SO -- LIKE
WITH THE SEEK ISSUE YOU KNOW WE
GET PEOPLE WHO ARE INTERESTED
BECAUSE WE HAVE PEOPLE COME HERE
FROM ALL OVER WE HAVE PEOPLE
COME FROM LEARNED SAN DIEGO --
LA COUNTY AND THEY HAVE
POTENTIAL VENDORS THAT WILL COME
WITH THEM BUT WHEN THEY HEAR THE
RATE THAT WE CAN THAT WE'RE
ALLOWED TO GIVE THEY SAID WE
CAN'T DO IT.
YOU'VE UNDOUBTEDLY HAD A A
BIGGER PRESENCE -- IN THE
COACHELLA VALLEY OVER THE LAST
YEAR AND A HALF AND I WANTED TO
ACKNOWLEDGE THAT AND APPRECIATE.
YOU BRING IN THE ENTIRE TEAM AND
THEM BEING INTRODUCED TO THE
COMMUNITY SO THAT PEOPLE KNOW
WHO THEY ARE.
WHAT THEIR ROLES AND
RESPONSIBILITIES ARE -- WITH I
RC AND THAT THAT'S EXTREMELY
IMPORTANT WHAT DOES THAT LOOK
LIKE ON A SUSTAINABLE LEVEL AS
IT RELATES TO HAVING THEIR
PRESENCE HERE AND I REPRESENT
ALL THE WAY TO THE NORTH SHORE
BOUNDARY WITH THE PEARL COUNTY.
DOWN TO IT BLIGHTED AREA THAT IS
SIGNIFICANTLY -- BUT LONG -- IN
TERMS OF THE DISTANCE TO BE ABLE
TO COME TO COACHELLA FROM LIFE
OR FOR THAT MATTER EVEN FROM THE
NORTH SHORE AREA WHAT IS.
AND OF THAT LOOK LIKE FOR YOU
MOVING FORWARD TO BE ABLE TO
SUSTAIN A A PERMANENT PRESENCE --
HERE IN THE COACHELLA VALLEY TO
HAVE PEOPLE A SEEK THE SERVICES
THAT YOU PROVIDE.
WELL -- IN A SEVERE THE LANHAM
ACT YOU KNOW WE WE WORK WITH THE
CONSUMERS IN THAN THEIR NATURAL
ENVIRONMENT AND THE COMMUNITIES
THAT THEY LIVE.
SO OUR STAFF MAY LIVE ANYWHERE
IN THE INLAND EMPIRE -- AND WE
HAVE TWO LOCATIONS ONE IN SAN
BERNADINO AND ONE IN RIVERSIDE.
SO WHEREVER THEIR OFFICES THEY
WOULD BE TRAVELING FROM THAT
LOCATION -- WE HAVE ALWAYS HAD A
PRESENCE IN BLYTH AND OUT HERE
IN THE LOWER DESERT AND THOSE
INDIVIDUALS ARE VISITING THEIR
CONSUMERS AS NEEDED.
AND WORKING WITH THE VENDORS
ALSO WE ALSO HAVE SOME -- A
LARGER -- VENDORS SUCH AS DESERT
ARC WHERE A LOT OF MEETINGS CAN
BE HELD SO WE MOVIE FORWARD --
WE HAVE TALKED WITH OUR INTAKE
DEPARTMENT AND WE WOULD LIKE TO
SET UP A CLINIC -- OUT IN THIS
AREA AND ALSO IN THE PAST WE'VE
ALSO HAD A SMALL SATELLITE
OFFICE IN PALM DESERT.
AND THOSE ARE THINGS THAT WE CAN
DO -- TO MAKE IT.
EASIER FOR FAMILIES -- TO JUST
SIT DOWN AND CHAT WE ALSO HAVE
DONE THIS IN THE PAST WITH A
SCHOOL DISTRICTS LIKE DESERT
SANDS IN PALM SPRINGS.
WE WITH YOU KNOW JUST HAVE
MEETINGS AND THEIR TO MAYBE
PUBLIC HEARINGS AND THINGS LIKE
THAT FOR OUR FAMILIES BUT OUR
OUR SERVICE COORDINATORS.
NEED TO BE VISITING.
THERE ARE CONSUMERS IN THEIR
HOMES IN THEIR WORK IN THEIR
SCHOOLS THANK YOU YOUR HONOR AND
IF WE CAN ADD YOU KNOW -- WE
APPRECIATE HAVING THE
OPPORTUNITY TO COME OUT HERE AND
BUT I SUSPECT THAT.
WE WOULD HAVE THAT SAME KIND OF
QUESTION IN INTEREST IF WE HAD --
THESE MEETINGS THROUGHOUT OUR
CATCHMENT AREA WE SERVE THE
TWENTY SEVEN THOUSAND SQUARE
MILES AND I'M SURE THE PEOPLE UP
IN.
YOU KNOW HYSTERIA IN VICTORVILLE
WOULD FEEL THAT SAME WAY AND
DOWN INTO MACULA AND THE I GUESS
THE THE POINT ONE OF THE THE
CHALLENGES THAT WE FACE IS THAT
NO MATTER WHERE WE ARE UNLESS WE
HAVE TONS OF DIFFERENT OFFICES --
WE HAVE A LOT OF TRAVELING TO DO
FROM FROM THE BASE WERE GROWING
AT A TREMENDOUS RATE AND WE
DON'T KNOW WHAT THAT WILL BE FOR
THE FUTURE -- YOU KNOW
LEGISLATIVELY WHAT WE'RE FOR
MORE THAN ONE REGIONAL CENTER I
DON'T VOTE WILL BE AT FORTY
THOUSAND BEFORE LONG -- THE THE
GROWTH IS A HUGE CHALLENGE FOR
US NOT JUST OUR SIZE BUT THE
GROWTH.
I WANT TO SAY -- I STRONGLY
BELIEVE THAT.
AT THAT YOU ARE ARE COVERING A
LOT OF AREA AND THE THE QUESTION
HERE IS ABOUT.
WHETHER OR NOT -- AND THIS MAY
BE A A RADICAL YOU KNOW THINKING.
TO MAKE SENSE OF THE CATCHMENT
AREA BE.
TURNED INTO TWO AREAS A GIVEN
THE LARGE TERRITORY THAT YOU'RE
COVERING -- IN DECEMBER -- DINO
AND RIVERSIDE AREA.
COUNTY AREA.
M. M. YEAH I'D LOVE TO GET YOUR
YOUR TAKE ON THAT -- CERTAINLY
IT'S SOMETHING THAT WE THINK
ABOUT WE HAVE -- CONSIDERED AND
AND HAVE A LOOK AT PROPERTIES AT
RIVERSIDE COUNTY FOR A LARGER
PRESENCE -- WE HAVE A HUNDRED
STAFF IN THE RIVERSIDE OFFICE
AND WE COULD MOVE OUT OVER A
HUNDRED MORE IF WE COULD -- ABLE
TO TO DO THAT UNFORTUNATELY IT
JUST HASN'T BEEN -- SOMETHING
THAT HAVE BEEN APPROVED FOR US
OR SOMETHING THAT WE CAN --
FINANCIALLY MANAGE AT THIS TIME
BUT IT IT IS ON OUR WOULD WOULD --
THIS CATCHMENT AREA BE THE
LARGEST IN THE STATE OF
CALIFORNIA.
WHAT AND WHO WOULD BE THE SECOND
AND WHAT'S THE KIND OF?
DIFFERENCE THAN AND MAYBE
GEOGRAPHIC TERRITORY AND AND
PERHAPS EVEN IN POPULATION
THAT'S BEEN SIR.
WOULD YOU WOULD YOU KNOW I WOULD
MÙT RIGHT NOW AND WE TALK
ABOUT WE'RE ALMOST A FORTY
THOUSAND IS PRETTY EVENLY SPLIT
200-002-0000 RIVERSIDE SAN
BERNADINE NOW.
BECAUSE IT'S CATCHING UP -- MORE
HOMES ARE BEING BUILT IN
RIVERSIDE COUNTY.
AND SO WE'RE WE'RE SEEING THIS.
THIS DOES PRETTY MUCH EQUALITY
WITH THE WITH THE DIVISION SO I
WILL SHARE WITH YOU YOU ARE
LISTENING THROUGH THE HEARINGS
THAT WE HAD TO DEATH WITHIN --
SIX THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA WE
INTRODUCED AB SIX TWENTY SEVEN
SO REGIONAL CENTERS WILL HAVE
THE ABILITY TO DO THAT SATELLITE
FACILITIES.
IN LARGE RURAL AREAS SO THIS IS
ONE OF THE POSSIBILITIES.
FOR GOOD YOUR IDEAS AND IN FACT
I UP.
I'M I'M WONDERING YOU KNOW OF A
A LARGER PRESENCE OUT HERE IN MY
OPINION ONE ACTUALLY LEAD TO
MORE -- CONSUMERS.
ARE.
CURRENTLY IT'S MENTIONED -- BY
YOUR COMMENTS AT TWO THOUSAND OF
THE CLOSE TO FORTY THOUSAND ARE
FROM THIS AREA I I I I IT'S HARD
FOR ME TO THINK THAT THAT'S THE
POPULATION AND ONLY POPULATION
THAT'S OUT HERE AND SO -- HOW DO
YOU ANTICIPATE YOU KNOW -- BEING
ABLE TO WITHIN THE MEMBERS OF
YOUR BUDGETS AND PERSONNEL AND
THAT AS PEOPLE'S HEARING SEE YOU
HERE IN THE COACHELLA VALLEY
THAT.
SCHOOL DISTRICT BEGINS TO SEND
PEOPLE THERE ARE OFFICE SINCE
PEOPLE THERE.
WHAT WHAT IS THAT LOOK LIKE FOR
YOU IN THE INSTANCE AT A IN ONE
YEAR YOU GET? FIVE HUNDRED
PEOPLE THAT ALL OF A SUDDEN ARE.
NEW TO I RC SERVICES.
WE ACTUALLY FACE THAT CHALLENGE
NOW -- AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE
I MEAN WE'RE WE'RE TRYING TO SAY
THAT YOU KNOW GOING FORWARD IT
IS NOT GOING TO BE YOU KNOW
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE SPENDING AN
AVERAGE OF TEN THOUSAND PER
CLIENT PER YEAR -- WE'RE GOING
TO NEED MORE BY DEFINITION OF
FOR GOING TO PROVIDE SERVICES TO
PEOPLE WHO ARE NOT RECEIVING
SERVICES IT'S GOING TO COST MORE --
AND IT'S GONNA INVOLVE MORE
PEOPLE -- EVEN THOUGH THERE MAY
BE A LOT MORE PEOPLE HERE THAT
MAY BE ELIGIBLE I SUSPECT THAT'S
THE CASE THROUGHOUT THE STATE --
YOU KNOW WHILE WE'RE CERTAINLY
AT WITH THREE HUNDRED AND TAKES
A MONTH -- WHAT WERE THE WORD IS
OUT BUT -- YOU KNOW IT IS OUR
GROWTH IS IS CERTAINLY --
EVIDENCE OF THAT THAT -- BUT
YEAH THE GROWTH IS A PROBLEM.
MY MY MAYBE WE GET CLOSE TO MY
FINAL QUESTION RIGHT AND I
APPRECIATE THE REFERENCES.
TO OTHER PARTS OF THE STATE.
ARE PARTICULARLY OTHER PARTS OF
THE I. R. C. TERRITORY -- I
CERTAINLY WILL LET MY COLLEAGUES
THAT REPRESENT THOUGH THERE IS
NO THAT I OUR STATE IS THINKING
ABOUT THEM AND THE NEEDS.
IN THOSE REGIONS -- BUT FOR ME
HERE IN THE COACHELLA VALLEY IN
IN THE BLIGHTED AREA RIGHT I GET
TO INTERFACE WITH PEOPLE WHY
REPRESENT YEAR AND ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT COMES UP REGULARLY.
IS WHAT IS THE JOB THAT PROCESS
INTERNALLY FOR THE PURPOSE OF
OVERSIGHT AND ACCOUNTABILITY OF
THE CASE WORK THAT'S HAPPENING --
OFTEN TIMES -- ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT COMES TO OUR ATTENTION IS
BUT WE'RE NOT HEARING BACK FROM
OUR REPRESENTATIVE WERE NOT --
GETTING CLEAR AND CONCISE
RESPONSES TO THE QUESTIONS WERE
NOT UNDERSTANDING WHAT THE
APPEAL PROCESS IS IS -- TO MAKE
SURE THAT UP WE WERE -- VETTED --
ENTIRELY AS IT RELATES TO THE
SERVICES THAT WERE SEEKING OUT
WOULD YOU WALK US THROUGH WHAT
THAT PROCESS LOOKS LIKE FOR
THOSE THAT ARE HERE THE THOSE
ARE WATCHING IN TERMS OF WHAT
THAT OVERSIGHT ACCOUNTABILITY
LOOKS LIKE.
THE ONE ON THE FOR YOU OUR
INTERNAL STRUCTURE IS PROBABLY
THE BEST WAY TO GO ABOUT THAT
POINT WHEN SOMEBODY GOES THROUGH
IN TANKER COMES YOU'RE FROM
ANOTHER ARIAN IS ASSIGNED A CASE
MANAGER.
IN FACT IN THE PAST WE USED TO
REQUIRE THAT EVERYBODY BE SEEN
QUARTERLY -- AND BECAUSE OF THE
GROWTH THE END INCREASES AND
DEMANDS OF WHAT THEY NEEDED TO
DO AND BECAUSE OF OUR GROWTH
HERE -- WE MADE.
THEY REQUIREMENTS.
IS ACTUALLY A ONE YEAR ONCE A
YEAR AND THEN AS NEEDED WE WERE
REQUIRING EVERY QUARTER.
BUT WE WENT BACK TO THE FIFTH IF
THE FAMILY FELT THAT ONE YEAR
ONCE YOU'RE WAS OKAY THEN THAT'S
THAT'S OKAY -- WE WOULD LIKE IN
FACT I'VE BEEN GOING AROUND A
MEETING WITH THE DIFFERENT UNITS
AND ENCOURAGING THEM TO MAKE
INFORMAL CONTACTS THEY LIKE AND
EVERY FRIDAY OR WHATEVER.
IN CALLING FAMILIES AND THAT
THEY HAVEN'T TALKED TO IN
SOMETIME JUST TO ESTABLISH
CONTACT AND SAY HAND YOUR CASE
WORKER AND THAT KIND OF THING
JUST TO BUILD RELATIONSHIPS
BECAUSE YOU CAN'T BUILD
RELATIONSHIPS IN A YEAR.
BUT THE CASE MANAGERS BECAUSE OF
OUR GROWTH WE CHANGE CASE LAWS
WE HAVE TO KEEP HIRING NEW
PEOPLE.
AND THEY NEED THEY DO TAKE SOME
TIME TO TRAIN AND AND YEAH WE
MAKE MISTAKES AND THEY DON'T
RESPOND SOMETIMES AND THEY DON'T
RETURN YOUR CALL WE GET THAT AND
AND WE WE ACKNOWLEDGE THAT.
AND AND ARE WORKING ON THAT BUT
EACH UNIT HAS ANYWHERE FROM
ABOUT FIFTEEN TO ADMIT EVEN
TWENTY CASE MANAGERS EACH OF
THOSE HAS A PROGRAM MANAGER.
AND IN EACH OF THE PROGRAM
MANAGERS HAS A THE DIRECTOR OVER
THEM DIRECTOR OF CHILDREN'S
SERVICES.
IN DIRECTOR OF ADULT SERVICES IN
THOSE TWO AND THEY'RE THEY'RE
NOT HERE TONIGHT BUT DOWN MESA
AND FULLY BAKER SEE ARE THOSE
TWO DIRECTORS.
AND OUR OUR PROGRAM MANAGERS TO
THE THE SCHOOL AGE IN TRANSITION
ARE HERE TONIGHT -- AND THEN WE
OVERSEE THE DIRECTORS.
SO THAT'S KIND OF THE THE
STRUCTURE IN IF YOU HAVE A
FAMILY OR A CONSUMER.
IS NOT GIVEN THE SERVICE THAT
THEY WANT.
THE WAY IT SHOULD WORK AS THEY
SHOULD GET A NOTICE OF ACTION.
THAT EXPLAINS TO THEM -- THAT
THERE AREN'T THERE STILL.
IS NOT BEING.
GRANTED EVEN IF IT'S NOT
PARTIALLY GRANTED.
AND WE THE I NOTICE OF ACTUAL
SITE.
THE LAND REGULATION FOR THEIR
REASON AND THAT AND THEY HAVE
THE RIGHT TO APPEAL THAT.
AND AFTER THE APPEAL WHEN THAT
APPEAL LETTER GOES OUT THEY CAN
MEDIATE OR THEY CAN HAVE AN
INFORMAL MEETING.
AND THEN IT'S ULTIMATELY SEEN BY --
OVER HEARD BY AN ADMINISTRATIVE
LAW JUDGE MAKES THAT DECISION.
INDEPENDENT FROM US -- TWO MORE
QUESTIONS ONE IS -- KIND OF A
OVER VIEW OF HOW YOU'RE LOOKING
AT THE SPANISH SPEAKING
POPULATION -- THAT -- GUYS.
CONFRONTED WITH JUST A BIT MORE
CHALLENGES RIGHT -- THE YOU
REPRESENTED ARE YOU INTRODUCED
I'M SORRY -- REPRESENTATIVE THAT
DEALS WITH THAT KIND OF CULTURAL
ASPECTS OF THE OPERATION WHAT
WHAT DOES THAT LOOK LIKE IN IN
ITS KIND OF BEEN TIRED -- WE
HAVE BILINGUAL COUNSELORS AND WE
HAVE -- ARE BOTH OF OUR
DIRECTORS FOR THE BIG GARCIA AND
ALL MESA -- SPEAKS SPANISH --
AND CENTER RUIZ WHO IS THE
PROGRAM MANAGER FOR THE ADULT
SERVICES OUT HERE SHE IS
ACTUALLY FROM THIS AREA SHE'S
FROM COACHELLA.
HER MOTHER LIVES IN COACHELLA
AND SO -- AS SHE SPEAKS SPANISH
AND SO A OUR SERVICE
COORDINATORS ARE SIGNED A
CASELOAD BASED ON THE THE END OF
THE CULTURE AWARENESS THAT THAT
THE KNOWLEDGE OF THE CULTURE --
AND THE ABILITY TO SPEAK THE
LANGUAGE.
OF SO -- YOU KNOW WE'RE SOME OF
US CAME TO THE INLAND EMPIRE AND
MANY OF US WERE HERE.
SO WE'RE REALLY PART OF THIS
CULTURE OF RIVERSIDE COUNTY AND
I TURN THE LOWER DESERT.
AND AS YOU GET TO KNOW THE
SERVICE COORDINATORS YOU'LL FIND
THAT THESE ARE THE PEOPLE WHO
WANT TO COME OUT HERE THEY WANT
TO BE HERE THEY'VE LIVED HERE.
AND WHEN WE TRY TO MATCH THAT AS
OFTEN AS WE CAN.
AS FAR AS OUR OUTRAGE GOALS THAT
WE ON A GOVERNOR CO WHO IS HERE
THIS ACTUALLY OUR DIVERSITY
SPECIALIST AT THE REGIONAL
CENTER -- SO I MEAN THAT'S
THAT'S WHEN HER FOCUS.
HER THAT IS HER FOCUS HERE AND
ONE OF OUR OTHER YOU KNOW THE
GOALS THAT WE HAVE IS TO DO OUR
REGION TO GET SERVICES TO PEOPLE
THAT HAVE NOT BEEN RECEIVING
SERVICES.
IN ONE OF THOSE SERVICES THAT'S
BENEFICIAL I WOULD SAY AN
APPLICANT APPLICABLES PROBABLY
OUT HERE IS RESPITE AND AND AS
WE'VE INDICATED WE HAD FOR NEW
FOUR THOUSAND NEW RESPITE
AUTHORIZATIONS LAST YEAR.
AND SO WE FEEL THAT THAT OUR
REACH.
IS BEING EFFECTIVE -- CURRENTLY
HE IS MY LAST QUESTION NALA WELL
AND THEN I'LL JUST CLOSE WITH
THE STATEMENT -- MY QUESTION IS --
IT CURRENTLY WHAT IS THE
MECHANISM TO ENSURE THAT THE
STUDENTS.
FROM THE KEY TO TWELVE SYSTEM.
ARE ARE BEING ENROLLED --
WITHOUT ANY INTERRUPTION TO
ENSURE THAT -- ONCE THEY TURN
EIGHTEEN ONCE THEY'RE OUT OF THE
PUBLIC EDUCATION SYSTEM THEY'RE
NOW INTEGRATED INTO THE REGIONAL
CENTER -- SERVICE PROVIDING --
ACTIVITIES -- AND PROGRAMS.
I'M I'M NOT SURE I'M CLEAR ON
THE QUESTION.
SO ONE OF THE THINGS THAT --
WE'VE HEARD FROM OUR LOCAL
CONSTITUENTS IS THAT -- THEY
WERE UNAWARE -- ONCE THEY LEAVE
HIGH SCHOOL THAT WERE UNDER
WHERE THE THE OF THE NEED TO BE
ABLE TO CONTINUE.
RECEIVING CERTAIN SERVICES AT
THE STATE CALIFORNIA HAS
GUARANTEED -- UP POPULATION THAT
THE IN ROLE PRIOR TO LEAVING
HIGH SCHOOL AND SO I'M CURIOUS
TO KNOW WHAT IS THE PARTNERSHIP
LOOK LIKE -- TO ENSURE THAT --
STUDENTS LEAVING THE K. TO
TWELVE SYSTEM ARE SEAMLESSLY
BEING TRANSITION INTO THE I. R.
C. CATCHMENT AREA TO BE ABLE TO
CONTINUE TO PROMOTE ME QUITE A
WHAT SERVICES.
AS AS A PARTNERS WITH THE THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE FAMILY WE
ATTEND THE I. E. P. AS SOON AS A
CHILD IS AGE.
THREE AND WE WERE THERE TO
ADVOCATE FOR THEM -- WE ARE
INVITED TO THOSE MEETINGS AND BY
DEVELOPING A GOOD RELATIONSHIP
WITH THE FAMILY IN THE SCHOOLS
THAT NORMALLY THE CASE.
THE TRANSITION PLAN -- BEGINS AT
AGE SIXTEEN AND WE ARE THERE TO
DISCUSS WHAT'S GOING TO HAPPEN
WITH THAT PERSON ONCE THEY'RE
OUT OF SCHOOL SOME OF OUR
CONSUMER STAY IN SCHOOL UNTIL
THE AGE OF TWENTY TWO SOME DO
EXIT AT AGE.
EIGHTEEN BUT WE DO HAVE WE HAVE
SERVICES FOR THOSE THAT WANT TO
CONTINUE TO GO TO COLLEGE.
THAT WANT A DIFF A VARIETY OF
PROGRAMS THAT WE DO HAVE OUT
HERE.
AND WE HAVE ANDREW AND BASS WHO
ARE HERE THEY ARE THE THE
EMPLOYMENT SPECIALIST AND THEY
WILL HELP -- TO BRIDGE THAT GAP --
NORMALLY AFTER SCHOOL THERE ARE
SERVICES THAT WE PROVIDE -- AND
IT'S JUST YOU KNOW DEPENDS ON
WHAT THE INDIVIDUAL WANTS AND
WHAT THEIR NEEDS ARE.
IN THE THE MORE RECENTLY OR THAT
THE CMS YOU KNOW AND AND CMS
RULE -- AS YOU MAY OR MAY NOT BE
FAMILIAR WITH THIS IS REALLY
EMPHASIZING.
INDIVIDUATION AND YOU KNOW CAN
UNITY INTEGRATION AND AS A
RESULT OF THAT A LOT OF THE
CENTER BASED TYPE WORK ACTIVITY
WORKSHOP TYPE PROGRAMS APPEND
LESS AND LESS FOCUSED ON IN MORE.
INDIVIDUAL SITUATIONS AND YOU
KNOW THAT'S WHY TRANSPORTATION
IS SUCH A BIG CONCERN FOR US AND
YOU KNOW WHAT THE THE RATE STUDY.
WAS GOING TO DO A LOT OF DAMAGE
TO OUR OUR TRANSPORTATION ISSUES
AROUND HERE.
AND THINGS LIKE THAT ARE A
CONCERN BECAUSE YOU KNOW WE
DON'T.
TAKE WE DON'T GET CLIENTS IN OUR
SYSTEM AT EIGHTEEN WE HAVEN'T
THROUGHOUT THE AGE SPAN AND AND
PART OF THE TRANSITION PLANET
SCHOOL THEIR I. T. P. SHOULD
INCLUDE US IN THERE -- BUT IT'S
IT'S A PARTNERSHIP BETWEEN US IN
THE SCHOOL IT ISN'T IT ISN'T
REALLY JUST A HAND OFF.
ALLEN WITH THIS AND I THINK --
THE WORD PARTNERSHIP IS IS WHERE
I WANT TO TAKE THIS I WANT.
TO SAY THAT I WANT TO BE A
PARTNER -- IN THE WORK THAT
YOU'RE DOING AND I WANT YOU TO
SEE US AS AN ADVOCATE -- IN THE
STATE LEGISLATURE AS IS --
CHAIRMAN FRAZIER TO THE WORK YOU
DO -- WE WANT TO MAKE SURE THAT
YOU'RE TELLING US WHAT IT IS
THAT YOU NEED HERE I IN ORDER TO
PROVIDE THE MOST EFFECTIVE AND
EFFICIENT SERVICES -- TO OUR
CONSTITUENTS AND THAT'S MY
INTEREST -- FOR ME THIS IS BEEN
A VERY EYE OPENING -- IN NEW
ARENA OF PUBLIC POLICY -- TO
UNDERSTAND AND CERTAINLY WE'RE
STILL LEARNING AS WE GO AND AND
THAT'S THE PURPOSE OF THE
QUESTIONS -- AND THE COMMENTS
THAT WERE MADE YOU KNOW YOU
STARTED OFF WITH BEING -- SELF
CRITICAL OF SOME OF THE
SHORTCOMINGS THAT YOU HAVE I
THINK IT WOULD BE MOST
APPROPRIATE THAT PERHAPS YOU
TELL US A LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
POSITIVE THINGS THAT ARE GOING
ON AND I I RC AS WE WRAP UP THIS
PANEL.
AND WE MOVE ON TO THE NEXT.
ONE WELL THERE'S A LOT OF
POSITIVE THINGS GOING ON I THINK
ESTABLISHING THE RELATIONSHIP.
AND HAVING THE CONSUMERS ARE
PRIORITY -- MOST OF US WHO YOU
KNOW I WAS A SERVICE COORDINATOR
SO I KNOW WHAT IT'S LIKE -- IT'S
A BOND.
AND IT'S A COMMITMENT AND NINE
IN AND WORKING WITH THE FAMILY
WORKING THAT WITH THE CONSUMER
AND WATCHING THEM GROW AND ALL
OF THEIR SUCCESSES.
IS -- IT'S IT'S JUST SOMETHING
THAT REALLY IT JUST GETS TO YOU
BECAUSE YOUR HEART IT'S A
COMMITMENT -- AND IT'S JUST IT'S
A VOCATION IS JUST SOMETHING
THAT YOU WANT TO DO AND YOUR
COMMITTED TO DOING IT.
OUR CONSUMERS ARE THE MOST
BEAUTIFUL PEOPLE.
AND THEY ALSO THOSE THAT ALSO
NEED A LOT OF SUPPORT AND HELP
IN THE COMMUNITY.
EDUCATING THE COMMUNITY BEING
OUT IN THE COMMUNITY THE THINGS
THAT WE'RE DOING -- I AM VERY
PROUD OF THE PEOPLE THAT ARE
HERE TODAY FOR IN THE REGIONAL
CENTER BECAUSE EITHER THE THE
THE SHAKERS THESE ARE THE PEOPLE
THAT ARE DOING THINGS --
TRAINING ON PERSON CENTERED
PLANNING -- COLLABORATING WITH
THE COMMUNITY AND JUST BEING
THERE COMING YOU KNOW JUST
CALLING APPARENT WHEN THEY'RE
HAVING SOME PROBLEMS AND JUST
HOLDING SOMEBODY'S HAND.
THOSE ARE THE THINGS WE DO AND I
THINK THAT AS AN AGENCY WE ARE
FAMILY -- OUR STAFF THEY COME IN
THIS DAY AND IF THEY LEAVE THEY
COME BACK IT'S A WONDERFUL PLACE
TO WORK AND I JUST REALLY FEEL
THAT.
THE SYSTEM IN CALIFORNIA IS THE
BEST IN THIS NATION.
AND I AM COMMITTED FOR LIFE AND
I HAVE A GRANDSON SO.
AND HE HAS REAP THE BENEFITS OF
IT.
IN IN AND IF I CAN SAY YOU KNOW --
LIVING AND I HAVE BOTH AND THAT
THE REGIONAL CENTER A LONG TIME
AND THERE WERE TIMES IT WAS
DIFFICULT THERE AND THAT WE HAD
ISSUES WITH THAT A HOSTILE WORK
ENVIRONMENT.
ASIAN AND YOU KNOW OUR ON ITS
HAVE BEEN GOOD LATELY IN THE
LAST THREE YEARS AND WE'VE BEEN
OUR POSITION FOR AND WE WE MADE
A COMMITMENT TO TURN THAT
ATTITUDE AROUND.
BOTH INTERNALLY AND WITH THE
COMMUNITY AND AS YOU KNOW -- IN
DECEMBER OF TWENTY FIFTEEN WE
HAD THE TERRORIST ATTACK THERE
AND THAT REALLY.
IT DID CREATE A LOT OF ANXIETY
AND FEAR AND BUT AT THE SAME
TIME IF YOU IF YOU LOOK AT FOR
YOU KNOW THE BRIGHT SIDE OF OF
HORRIBLE THINGS -- IT DID PULL
US TOGETHER AND IT PULLED THE
COMMUNITY TOGETHER AND A LOT OF
THE TREATY -- TRIVIAL ISSUES
THAT YOU KNOW SEPARATE PEOPLE
DID KIND OF GO BY THE WAYSIDE WE
WERE ABLE TO BUILD ON THAT
SOMEONE.
AND YOU KNOW WE WE TRY TO HAVE --
YOU KNOW REDUCE.
THE FEAR AMONG STAFF TO BE
CREATIVE AND BE INNOVATIVE AND
AND COME UP WITH SOME NEW IDEAS
AND WE'RE TRYING TO DO THAT IN
THE COMMUNITY AS WELL.
BECAUSE OF OUR OF OUR CASE
MANAGERS ARE HAVE A DIFFERENT
ATTITUDE THEY'LL BRING THAT INTO
THE COMMUNITY AND AND IT WAS
DIFFICULT FOR YEARS AND THAT
GOES BACK TO WHEN YOU KNOW THE
WHEN I SAY THEY WERE.
KIND OF CHEAP AND IF WE HAD A
LITTLE WHAT KIND OF PAYING THE
PRICE FOR THAT NOW WE'RE TRYING --
TO TRYING TO REVERSE THAT.
AND WE THINK WE'VE BEEN SINCE
SOME SOMEWHAT SUCCESSFUL AND AND
WE WERE TOP WORKPLACE. TWO YEARS
IN A ROW IN THE INLAND EMPIRE.
SO WE'RE PROUD OF THAT AND WE'RE
PROUD OF THE STAFF THAT WE THANK
YOU AGAIN -- FOR YOUR TIME IN
LOOKING FORWARD TO THE CONTINUED
PARTNERSHIP AN ONGOING.
DIALOGUE -- FOR US TO IMPROVE ON
THE AREAS THAT YOU -- SOFT
PRETTY.
AND I THINK THAT MANY OF THE
FOLKS HERE WOULD NOT NOT
DISAGREE.
ALTHOUGH SOME OF THE
SHORTCOMINGS I WOULD BET THAT
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT YOU JUST
MENTIONED IN YOUR CLOSING
COMMENTS.
SOME OF THINGS THAT SOME PEOPLE
HERE DO ALSO LINE WITH TERMS OF
THE GOOD THINGS ARE HAPPENING AT
RC THANK YOU AGAIN FOR YOUR TIME
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU THANK YOU FOR HAVING
US.
I WANT TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH
FOR THE INFORMATIVE PRESENTATION
I ALSO WANTED AGAIN.
THANK YOUR STAFF FOR MY R. C. TO
BE HERE ON A FRIDAY NIGHT ON
YOUR OWN TIME. TO MEET WITH A
COMMUNITY.
THAT IS VERY TELLING.
OF YOUR PASSION.
AND YOUR COMMITMENT TO THE
COMMUNITIES WANT TO THANK STAFF
ALSO.
NEXT WE'LL HEAR FROM DOCTOR
EDWIN GOMEZ SUPERINTENDENT THE
COACHELLA VALLEY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
AND JESSICA HOW.
RECTOR OF SPECIAL EDUCATION THE
COACH.
COACHELLA VALLEY UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT DOCTOR GOMEZ
[INAUDIBLE]
YEAH.
THE DOCTOR WILL GO ON AS YOU
HAVE THE FLOOR THANK YOU VERY
MUCH AND A GOOD EVENING SOME
WOMEN FRAZIER AND ASSEMBLY MAN
MR GARCIA.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR HAVING US
TONIGHT TO BE ABLE TO EXPRESS
OUR VOICES.
I'M THE PROUD SUPERINTENDENT OF
THE COACHELLA VALLEY UNIFIED
SCHOOL DISTRICT WHERE SCHOOL
DISTRICT HAS.
OVER EIGHTEEN THOUSAND STUDENTS
WERE PROBABLY ONE OF THE HIGHEST
POVERTY SCHOOL DISTRICTS IN THE
STATE OF CALIFORNIA.
OUR SCHOOL DISTRICT SPANS ABOUT
TWELVE HUNDRED AND FIFTY MILES
OF SQUARE.
MILES THROUGHOUT THE RIVERSIDE
AND IMPERIAL COUNTIES.
SO WE'RE DEFINITELY A A DISTRICT
I PROMISE WE HAVE A LOT OF NEEDS
FOR OUR STUDENTS AND WE
APPRECIATE THE FACT THAT YOU'RE
HERE. TO TO HEAR OUR VOICE AND
TO REALLY UNDERSTAND SOME OF THE
COMPLEXITIES INVOLVED IN OUR
STUDENTS AND TONIGHT.
AYE AYE WE DO HAVE DOCTOR HOUSE
AND WE HAVE THIS IS THAT TWENTY
DS LINE -- THIS IS THE ESTÁN
DOES WORK WITH OUR DISTRICT IN
PARTNERING AND HELPING OUR
STUDENTS THAT ARE TRANSITIONAL
SERVICES SOMEONE TO PASS THE
TIME.
HI THANK YOU FOR HAVING US I'M
I'M THE DIRECTOR OF SPECIAL
EDUCATION FOR THE CONTROL OF A
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT WE HAVE
OVER TWENTY TWO HUNDRED STUDENTS.
I'M WITH VARYING DISABILITIES
WITH OUR STUDENTS THAT ARE IN
THE TRANSITIONAL AGE WE REALLY
TRY TO PROVIDE SUPPORT -- TO NOT
ONLY AT THE SCHOOL BUT ALSO
THROUGH OUR WORKABILITY GRANT.
THE PURPOSE OF THE TRANSITIONAL
SERVICES THAT WE PROVIDE ARE NOT
ONLY TO ASSESS STUDENTS
INTERESTS BUT ALSO CONNECT THEM
WITH DIFFERENT PROGRAMS SUCH AS
I R. C..
OR DOES THE DARK OR POWELL'S
THAT ARE WITHIN OUR AREA -- THE
TRANSITIONAL SERVICES THAT WE
PROVIDE REALLY FOCUS ON THE
STUDENTS THE COMMUNITY AND
DIFFERENT SERVICES THAT WE CAN
CONNECT THEM WITH -- ARE
TRANSITIONAL SERVICES INCLUDE
WORKABILITY ARE WORKABILITY
GRANT GIVES US ACCESS TO AN
INDIVIDUAL THAT HELP SUPPORT --
DOING THESE ASSESSMENTS
THROUGHOUT OUR DISTRICT AS WELL
AS PROVIDING OPPORTUNITIES
BRINGING THEM INTO THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT OR TAKING THE STUDENTS
TO OTHER PLACES.
THE PROGRAM -- FOCUSES ON
STUDENTS THAT ARE SIXTEEN TO
TWENTY TWO YEARS OLD REALLY
LOOKING AT VOCATIONAL INTERESTS
PARTNERING THEM WITH JOBS OR A
DIFFERENT WORK EXPERIENCES.
THROUGH OUR TRANSITIONAL SUPPORT
WE'VE BEEN LUCKY ENOUGH TO
PARTNER WITH TONY DESIGN.
AND I'M SHE'S GOING TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT THE
TRANSITIONAL SERVICES THAT SHE'S
BEGAN SUPPORTING OURS STUDENTS
WITH THIS YEAR.
GOOD AFTERNOON I AM AN ATTORNEY
HI ALL MY PRO BONO SIDE OF MY
LIKE DEDICATE.
MY SERVICES TO ASSISTING
INDIVIDUALS WITH.
DISABILITIES IN THIS PARTICULAR
CASE DEVELOPMENTAL DISABILITIES
I TO REGISTER FOR SERVICES I
WORK THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA BUT I
AM FROM THE DESERT I GREW UP
HERE THIS IS MY MY LOVE MY HOME --
AND AS I'VE BEEN FOCUSING ON THE
DESERT LATELY AND PARTICULAR --
COLLABORATING WITH COULD TELL
ABOUT THE UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT THERE ARE UNIQUE --
CHALLENGES TO THIS PARTICULAR
DISTRICT THAT DON'T EXIST IN
OTHER PARTS OF A CALIFORNIA THAT
I HAVE NOTICED -- FIRST -- WHEN
I MEET WITH FAMILIES THE FIRST
THING THAT STRIKES ME IS THAT
THEY JUST DON'T KNOW WHO
REGIONAL CENTER IS?
THEY'VE NEVER HEARD OF IT.
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT THEY DO
THEY DON'T KNOW WHAT THE
SERVICES ARE.
THEY DON'T KNOW HOW TO APPLY AND
SO -- THAT'S OBVIOUSLY --
THERE'S A GAP.
IN INFORMATION AND SO THAT'S
OBVIOUSLY A BIG ISSUE -- ANOTHER
ISSUE IS -- IN LARGER CITIES --
BECAUSE THEY'RE OBVIOUSLY MORE
POPULATED YOU COULD PROBABLY
WALK TO REGIONAL CENTER AND
THAT'S A COUPLE BLOCKS AWAY OR
TAKE A BUS OR IN A VERY QUICKLY
GET THEIR YOU KNOW HERE.
I'M FROM FROM COULD TELL US -- I
RC SEVENTY FIVE MILES FROM MECCA
AT EIGHTY FIVE MILES AND WE'RE
TALKING ABOUT A POPULATION THAT
DOES NOT.
HAVE CARS IF ANY -- THEY HAVE A
SHARED INCOME THEY DON'T HAVE
INTERNET.
EVEN THOUGH INTERNET FOR ALL HAS
BEEN PASSED.
THEY DON'T HAVE PHONES TO
THEY'LL HAVE EMAIL THE DON'T
HAVE SCANNERS -- THE MOVE VERY
OFTEN AND SO TO MAINTAIN THAT
COMMUNICATION WITH THE REGIONAL
CENTER.
EVEN RECEIVE INFORMATION IS VERY
VERY DIFFICULT SO IT'S A UNIQUE
CHALLENGE TO THIS POP LUCIEN
HERE -- ALSO THE LANGUAGE
BARRIER -- THERE ARE INDIVIDUALS
WHO ARE PART OF THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT TO SPANISH IS ACTUALLY
THEIR SECOND LANGUAGE THE MY
HOPE THIS PARTICULAR DIALECT
FROM -- WHERE THEY'RE FROM INTO
SPANISH IS IS IT IS CHALLENGING
FOR THEM AS IT IS?
I'M.
WHEN WE ARE ATTEMPTING -- TO
REGISTER STUDENTS -- THE PROCESS
WELL IN MAY BE EASY FOR SOME
PEOPLE WERE TALKING ABOUT A
FAMILY WHO DOESN'T HAVE A HIGH
LEVEL OF EDUCATION OF THE
POVERTY.
OR MAY HAVE A DISABILITY
THEMSELVES APPLYING ONLINE IS
DIFFICULT.
THEY DON'T HAVE A SCANNER THE TO
HAVE YOU KNOW THAT I HAVE
COMPUTERS -- THAT TO GET THEIR
DOCUMENTS FROM SCHOOL SCANNED
THEM UPLOAD THEM IT'S VERY
CHALLENGING FOR PEOPLE AND SO
WE'RE TRYING -- TO IN MY
COLLABORATION WITH THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT FILL BACK UP -- BECAUSE
IT'S A IT'S A LARGE CAPSULE
ANALLY COMING OUT WALK INTO AN
OFFICE.
AND GET AN APPLICATION AND TALK
TO SOMEONE.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE ACCESS --
INTERVIEWS INTERNET OR SOCIAL
MEDIA.
CALLING THE REGIONAL CENTER IS
ALSO VERY.
VERY CHALLENGING A IT'S ALMOST
IMPOSSIBLE TO CALL AND GET
SOMEONE TO ANSWER -- AND IF
YOU'RE CALLING JUST FOR
INFORMATION HOW ARE YOU GONNA
KNOW FLOOD BUTTON TO PRESS AND
WHO TO TALK TO YOU.
AND MANY TIMES AGAIN WE'RE
DEALING WITH PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES AND THEIR FAMILIES.
THAT'S A VERY CHALLENGING
PROCESS AND SO -- I CAN'T STRESS
ENOUGH HOW IMPORTANT IT WOULD BE
TO HAVE A LOCAL OFFICE -- TO
HAVE A PLACE WHERE PEOPLE CAN
WALK IN WITH NORMAL BUSINESS
HOURS I HAVE TRIED TO ME MANY
TIMES -- REGIONAL CENTER
REPRESENTATIVES HERE AND THEY
HAVE NEVER TOLD ME THAT THEY
HAVE AN OFFICE OR A PLACE WHERE
WE CAN MEET SO WHERE.
EITHER MEETING AT THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT ONE THAT'S AN OPTION OR
A STARBUCKS OR RESTAURANTEUR ICE
CREAM SHOP OR WHATEVER IT IS AND
SO.
YOU KNOW THAT'S THAT'S ANOTHER
CHALLENGING ASPECT -- I EIGHT I
KNOW WE'VE HEARD A LITTLE BIT
ABOUT -- THE CULTURAL
SENSITIVITY BUT I REALLY CAN'T
STRESS ENOUGH HOW INTERACTION
WITH OUR COMMUNITY UNDERSTANDING
THAT THIS THAT THERE IS
AGRICULTURE HERE THE TYPES OF
JOBS THAT FAMILIES HAVE HERE --
WHERE THEY COME FROM IT'S JUST A
VERY IMPORTANT ASPECT TO NOT
ONLY DEALING WITH THE DISABILITY
ITSELF WHICH IS VERY COMPLICATED
OFTEN -- BUT JUST THE FAMILIES
AND AND AND THE AND
UNDERSTANDING WHAT THEIR NEEDS
ARE SO -- COACHELLA HAS DONE A
REALLY AMAZING JOB I GETTING THE
WORD OUT TO FAMILIES TO REGISTER
TO TRY TO GET THEM BEFORE THEY
LEAVE HIGH SCHOOL A WHILE THE
DOCUMENTS ARE STILL AVAILABLE --
SO I COMMEND THEM FOR MAKING
[INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
ANY OTHER COMMENTS.
I JUST THINK TO ATTACK -- WAY
TOO MANY HAVE STATED I THINK THE
ACCESSIBILITY PART IS IS
EXTREMELY IMPORTANT IN OUR
COMMUNITY.
AND WHAT I WOULD URGE THIS
COMMITTEE TO TO THINK ABOUT
RESPECTFULLY IS IS ALSO THE THE
ASPECTS OF CULTURAL SENSITIVITY
AND KEEPING IN MIND THAT A LOT
OF OUR FAMILIES SOMETIMES LIVE
IN FEAR BECAUSE OF THE
CIRCUMSTANCES.
ARE THE POLITICAL CLIMATE --
THAT THEY'RE FACED WITH AND IT'S
VERY VERY IMPORTANT FOR THEM TO
REALLY HAVE -- CONNECTIONS AND I
THINK THAT THE REASON WHY WE'VE
BEEN -- HEADED TOWARDS A A MORE
SUCCESSFUL PATH IS BECAUSE I
THINK WE UNDERSTAND THAT AND
WE'RE WORKING WITH PARTNERS TO
MAKE THAT HAPPEN -- FOR US TO TO
HAVE THAT FEASIBILITY THE
ACCESSIBILITY AND I BELIEVE THAT
THAT HAVING MORE INROADS IN THAT
DIRECTION WOULD BE HELPFUL.
THE JUST REGARDS TO THE
PARTNERSHIP WITH THE SCHOOL
DISTRICT AND IN AND REGIONAL
CENTERS.
IS THERE A POSSIBILITY AS YOU
KNOW -- SCHOOL DISTRICT IS IN --
CONSTRUCTION MOLD AND BUILDING
IN -- AND RENOVATING FACILITIES
THAT THERE COULD BE -- A VIABLE
PATH THERE TOO HAVING A
PARTNERSHIP -- YOU KNOW A TOOL
YOU KNOW PURPOSE FACILITY THAT
SERVES THE FAMILIES WITHIN YOUR
SCHOOL DISTRICT FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION NEEDS AND HAVING THEM
THERE -- ON A ON A FULL TIME
PRESENCE IS THAT SOMETHING
VIABLE THAT WE CAN PURSUANT.
AND IF NOT -- JUST DIRECTLY ON
YOUR OWN PERHAPS -- I AS THE
AVERAGE KID SACRAMENTO PUSH FOR
THIS TYPE OF RESOLUTION BE --
FUNDING MECHANISM THAT COULD ADD
TO IN ALL THAT CONVERSATION.
OBVIOUSLY WE WE ARE VERY OPEN TO
COLLABORATION WERE WERE OPEN TO
HAVING JOINT USES FOR FACILITIES
AND YOU KNOW THOSE ARE THINGS
THAT WE OBVIOUSLY HAVE TO WORK
WITH THE COMMUNITY AND WITH THE
PURPOSE OF A BOND.
BUT WE WOULD BE COMPLETELY OPEN
TO THAT SUPPORTS AND HAVING THAT
THAT DIFFERENCE AYE LAYER.
OF IF FUNDING PERHAPS FROM THE
STATE -- I THINK THAT WOULD BE
POWERFUL AND I THINK THAT WOULD
MEAN A LOT OF OUR NEEDS HERE IN
THE VALLEY.
THANK YOU ARE TWO YEARS AGO WE
AUTHORED LEGISLATION THAT CAME
FROM PARENTS OF SPECIAL NEEDS
STUDENTS.
THAT WANTED -- TO SCHOOL
DISTRICTS -- TO ON THEIR
APPLICATIONS A CONDITION THE BOX
THE INFORMATION.
THAT -- PARENTS WOULD HAVE
ACCESS TO INFORMATION REGARDING
THE ID PEAS -- A FEW DAYS IN
ADVANCE -- I GIVEN THAT THOSE
ARE WORKING -- DOCUMENTS IN
PROGRESS BUT THAT MANY TIMES --
CONSIDERING -- THE POPULATION AT
THAT WE ARE TALKING ABOUT HERE
IN THE EASTERN COACHELLA VALLEY.
THE THE FACT IS IS THAT -- THE
INFORMATION IS PRESENTED THAT
THE DAY OF THE MEETING -- IT
BECOMES VERY DIFFICULT TO TAKE
IN AND MAKE A A AND DECISION ON
WHETHER OR NOT THAT'S THE PLAN
MOVING FORWARD -- THE FOR THE
GOVERNOR OF VETO THE BILL ST
THAT TO MAYBE THAT COULD BE TOO
REDUNDANT.
I'M TOO MUCH WORK FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS I DIDN'T THINK SO --
BUT IS THERE SOMETHING THAT --
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT IS DOING.
A TO ENSURE THAT THAT --
INFORMATION IS BEING MADE
AVAILABLE -- IN A TIMELY MANNER
FOR THE PURPOSE OF BEING ABLE TO
DIGEST IT A BIT AND GO INTO A
CONVERSATION.
A LITTLE MORE INFORMED AND
EDUCATED ABOUT WHAT'S BEING
PRESENTED TO YOU AS A STUDENT I
KNOW I IT COMES TO MIND AS I RC
REPS SAID THEY ARE AT THE TABLE
WHEN THESE IDPS ARE BEING.
DEVELOPED -- PARENTS ARE AT THE
TABLE BUT MANY TIMES NOT --
MENTALLY -- PREPARED TO MAKE
THAT DECISION BECAUSE I JUST GOT
THIS DOCUMENT.
THAT SAYS THIS IS THE PLAN OF
ACTION WE FOR COULD YOU CAME IN
ON WHAT THAT LOOKS LIKE FOR THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND FOR SCHOOL DISTRICT IN THE
PARENT THE REQUEST TO HAVE THE
DOCUMENTATION EARLY ABSOLUTELY
IS PROVIDED IT -- WE ALSO
PROVIDE TRANSLATORS AT EVERY I.
P. TO ENSURE THAT THE
TRANSLATION AND THERE'S
UNDERSTANDING OF THE DOCUMENT.
I'M AT ANY TIME IF RECENT OR
NEED TO BE TAKEN OUR RECONVENE
MEETINGS NEED TO BE RE CONVENE
WITH NO SO TO THAT.
OF WE REALLY WANT THE PARENTS TO
BE A PART OF IT.
AND WANTED TO BE A SMOOTH
TRANSITION TO THE HIGHER SEE.
THANK YOU THANK YOU I DON'T HAVE
ANY OTHER QUESTIONS FOR ME.
THANK YOU FOR OUR PANEL FOR
COMING TODAY AND WE LOOK FORWARD
TO YOUR SUCCESS WITH THE
STUDENTS AND AGAIN YOUR PASSION
FOR THE COMMUNITY AND HELPING.
THEM ADVANCE. FOR THEIR
SUCCESSES AND ALSO.
YOU KNOW ONE IF YOU CAN BE
SUCCESSFUL.
WE DON'T HAVE TO PUT AS MANY
FOLKS AND REST A GROUP.
YEAH.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE FOR WELCOME
BECAUSE OF YOU [INAUDIBLE]
THANK.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR PARTICIPATION
YOU TODAY ONCE AGAIN THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE NOW WE WILL HEAR
FROM OUR SELF ADVOCATES REGINALD
DAVIS.
ADVOCATE AT DESERT ARC IN RONALD
L. OF THE I. R. C. APPOINTEE TO
THE STATEWIDE DISABILITY
ADVISORY COUNCIL [INAUDIBLE]
MON UP
STAR.
FOR YOU GET A GOOD EVENING
EVERYONE.
MY NAME IS RESIDENT DAVIS.
AND I AM VERY HONORED TO BE HERE
TONIGHT -- BASICALLY I'M GONNA
TALK ABOUT MY CHALLENGES LIVING
WITH CEREBRAL PALSY -- WHEN I
WAS YOUNG -- I JUST REALLY.
DIDN'T REALIZE HOW DIFFERENT.
IOWA IS [INAUDIBLE]
AND YOU KNOW BEING AROUND.
YOU KNOW MY FAMILY AND MY
FRIENDS.
YOU KNOW I JUST THOUGHT I WAS
NORMAL.
YOU KNOW I'M GOING TO THE DOCTOR
IS IN HAVING SURGERIES AND STUFF
LIKE THAT.
YOU KNOW IT WAS JUST VERY.
IT IS VERY SCHEME NORMAL TO ME.
BUT THEN MY APPEARANCE AND MY
GRANDMOTHER SAT ME DOWN AND
EXPLAINED TO ME.
YOU KNOW THIS IS THIS IS WHAT IT
WAS I HAVE SEVERAL OF THE AND
YOU KNOW THESE ARE SOME OF THE
THINGS YOU HAVE TO DO IT
[INAUDIBLE]
SO -- YOU KNOW IT TOOK ME IT
TOOK ME QUITE A LONG TIME TO
REALLY AGES IN KNOWLEDGE THE
FACT THAT I DO HAVE A DISABILITY.
AND THAT THERE ARE LIMITATIONS.
COMING WITH YOU KNOW COMING
ALONG WITH THAT [INAUDIBLE]
AND YOU KNOW -- I DIDN'T REALLY
START TO REALLY REALIZE.
MY LIMITATIONS AND SILVA HI.
GOT IN SCHOOL.
YOU KNOW MY FRIENDS WOULD BE
PLAYING RUNNING JUMPING IN YOU
KNOW A LOT OF THOSE THINGS CAME
EASY EASY TO THEM AND CAN DO
THAT SOME.
BUT AS I GOT OLDER YOU KNOW I I
REALIZE THAT IT'S YOU KNOW --
THAT I CAN JUST OVERCOME IT YOU
KNOW.
AND JUST.
LIVE WITH IT AND ONCE I GOT INTO
HIGH SCHOOL I REALLY JUST
STARTED TO QUESTION WHAT MY
PURPOSE WAS.
YOU KNOW LIVING WITH HIS
DISABILITY -- AND I JUST LEARNED
OVER TIME THAT.
IT'S OKAY TO BE DIFFERENT.
IT'S OKAY.
TO HAVE A WALKER YOU KNOW IT.
IT'S IT'S A PART OF YOU BUT IT
DOESN'T DEFINE YOU [INAUDIBLE]
AND ONCE I LEARNED THAT AND THEN
THAT'S WHEN I REALLY STARTED TO
LEARN THAT I WANTED.
TO BECOME INDEPENDENT.
AND START LIVING FOR ME.
IN SO AROUND THE TIME WHEN I WAS
TWENTY FIVE THAT'S WHEN I REALLY
STARTED TO VENTURE OUT ON MY OWN.
AND I WOULD SLOWLY STARTED TO
SEE HOW PEOPLE WOULD SEE ME.
IN SOCIETY -- I WILL BE LABELED
CRIPPLED. TO SOME DIFFERENT
THINGS MENTALLY YOU KNOW
CHALLENGED.
AND JUST STUFF LIKE THAT JUST
BECAUSE OF WHAT THE FEE BASED OF
BASED OFF OF WHAT THEY SEE.
AND I LEARNED THAT I SHOULD JUST
YOU KNOW.
BE ADVOCATE.
FOR PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES WHO
CANNOT STAND UP FOR THEMSELVES.
IN GE'S.
SPEAK OUT AND IS FIFTH DEFEND
MYSELF AS WELL AS OTHERS WITH
DISABILITIES.
IN IT TOOK SOME COURAGE TO DO
THAT BECAUSE I'M A VERY SHY
PERSON.
WHERE -- OVER TIME I KNEW I HAD
A PURPOSE.
AND IT'S SOMETHING THAT NEEDED
TO BE DONE [INAUDIBLE]
SO -- I STARTED.
LOOKING FOR JOBS YOU KNOW AND
WANTING TO WORK IN JUST LIVE A
NORMAL LIFE JUST LIKE EVERYONE
ELSE -- AND THEN I SLOWLY
STARTED TO REALIZE HOW THE
EMPLOYMENT.
SYSTEM.
CAN BE VERY FRUSTRATING.
AND THEN WHEN I WOULD GO ON JOB
INTERVIEWS.
THEY WOULD JUDGE ME. FOR THE
EVEN SPOKE TO ME [INAUDIBLE]
AND YOU KNOW I CAN JUST I CAN
JUST FEEL IT YOU KNOW
[INAUDIBLE]
AND THEM.
I JUST FELT AS THOUGH LIKE ONE
THEN HAVE BEEN I FELT AS THOUGH
THERE NEED TO BE A CHANGE.
AND I FELT AS THOUGH -- IN THEN
REGIONAL CENTER.
JUST NEEDS TO PROVIDE.
MORE -- TRAINING.
WHEN IT COMES TO WORKING WITH
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES?
AS FAR AS SENSITIVITY TRAINING.
BECAUSE THERE'S A LOT OF PEOPLE.
THAT CAN BE PREJUDICE.
AND JUST REALLY.
YOU KNOW NOT REALLY TAKE THE
TIME. TO GIVE US A CHANCE THAT
WE ACTS.
FOR AND THAT JUST NEEDS.
TO CHANGE [INAUDIBLE]
COME.
SO YEAH -- I I JUST REALLY DO
THINK.
THAT.
EVERYBODY WHO IS IN HERE TO NINE
WITH THE DISABILITY AND THAT WE
ARE ALL EQUAL.
JUST LIKE ANYONE ELSE YES WE
NEED ACCOMMODATIONS WHEN IT
COMES -- TO WORKING -- BECAUSE
OF THE PHYSICAL LIMITATIONS.
BUT WE CAN STILL WORK REGARDLESS.
AND I FEEL AS THOUGH WE SHOULD
STILL GET EQUAL PAY JUST LIKE
EVERYBODY ELSE.
IT SHOULDN'T BE ANY DIFFERENT --
AND I KNOW I SAID THAT IN THE
REGIONAL CENTER AND DOES NEED TO
PROVIDE MORE TRAINING.
BUT I THINK DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION CAN ALSO PROVIDE
TRAINING [INAUDIBLE]
TO AS WELL [INAUDIBLE]
AND AND I REALLY JUST
[INAUDIBLE]
BELIEVE THAT -- WE ALL HAVE A
PURPOSE HERE.
WE ALL HAVE A STORY [INAUDIBLE]
IN.
I'M JUST GLAD TO BE ONE OF THOSE
VOICES. TWO VENTURE OUT AND TO
GET THE WORD OUT.
AND LET PEOPLE KNOW THAT
[INAUDIBLE]
WE ARE.
WE ARE -- JUST AS EQUAL AS
EVERYBODY ELSE.
EQUALITY IS VERY IMPORTANT TO ME.
SELF WORTH IS VERY IMPORTANT TO
ME.
AND I FELL AS A LOT OF PEOPLE
WITH DISABILITIES.
NEED TO LEARN.
IT TAKES TIME.
I I WILL SAY THAT IT TAKES TIME
I'M STILL LEARNING HOW TO DEAL
WITH THAT HOW.
TO HAVE SELF WORTH AND TO REALLY
JUST LET MYSELF IN AT THE END OF
THE DAY.
AND JUST STAND UP FOR MYSELF
[INAUDIBLE]
SO [INAUDIBLE]
EVEN IF.
I TOUCH ONE PERSON.
TONIGHT WITH MY WORDS.
AND THEN I KNOW I DO MY JOB HERE
[INAUDIBLE]
REGINALD.
YOU'RE AN INSPIRATION TO ME
THANK YOU.
YOUR SMILE CONFECTIONS THINKING.
SO THANK YOU FOR THAT WE'RE
GONNA MOVE ON TO RUN WOULD GIVE
HIM SOME SPARE TIME OKAY.
MY NAME IS RANI ON AND THEN --
WE CUT I KNOW ADAM AND I'M BOUND
TO THAT.
BUT THAT'S ONE THING I WANT YOU
GUYS TO UNDERSTAND.
THE CLIENT ARE IMPORTANT TO
RETURN TO SENDER.
AND THEN.
IF THAT THERE WAS NO CLIENTS
HERE THERE WILL BE NO REGIONAL
CENTER.
AND I WANNA TASTE THEM I CAME
FROM A REGIONAL CENTER.
IT UNDERSTAND ME.
AND I UNDERSTOOD THEM.
I WILL I WAS ON THE CHAIRPERSON
FOR SELF DETERMINATION.
THAT ONE PROGRAM THAT WILL WORK.
THE END OF A LONG AND THAT THE
GOAL.
AND THE OTHER THING I'M OUT.
A COMPLAIN ABOUT IT.
AT HOME AND I EIGHTY EIGHTH.
THE PEOPLE ALTHOUGH THERE ARE
FORTUNATE PARENTS ABOUT MY BOOK --
BY THE NECK [INAUDIBLE]
THIS GROUP [INAUDIBLE]
I'M SHEET.
AT I LOVE THE CLIENT DON'T HAVE
COMPUTER WELL I'M A CLIENT DON'T
HAVE -- THE CELL PHONE.
FIND A PLAN SHE THEY WON'T THEY
THEY WANT THE THE BILL OF THE
NIGHT TIME SHE ON THE COMPUTER.
AND THEN MY CLIENT HAD THE
SENATE.
I'LL BE GOING TO SIGN IT WHEN
THEY DON'T HAVE A COMPUTER.
THE CELL PHONE.
NOT IF IF THE IF THE STATE WANT
THEM TO DO THAT THEN THEN THAT
THE STATE SHOULD GET HELP A
CLIENT GET FROM P. MIGHT THAT.
THAT -- ON WEDNESDAY
[INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE ALSO AMAZING THANK YOU
FOR YOUR ADVOCACY AND YOUR
PASSION.
AND STEELY NOTED.
AT THIS TIME WE WANT TO HEAR
FROM THE PUBLIC.
AND WE'RE HOPEFUL THAT -- ALL OF
YOU WHO ARE HERE AND AND WANT TO
CHIME IN ON THE CONVERSATION
FROM THE FIRST PANEL -- THE
SECOND OR THE THIRD WAY OUT BY
THE SELF ADVOCATES YOU THAT YOU
WOULD.
MAKE THOSE COMMENTS AND DIRECT
THEM TO THE CHAIRED MYSELF WE
WILL BE TAKING NOTE.
AS CHAIR SAID EARLIER THAT THESE
SELECT COMMITTEES ALLOW FOR US.
TO COME UP WITH IDEAS THAT COME
FROM THE COMMUNITY FROM YOU ALL
FOR POTENTIAL POLICY.
CHANGES AND YOU KNOW THE CHAIR
JUST SHARED SOMETHING WITH ME
THAT -- A HANDFUL.
OF PIECES OF LEGISLATION THAT HE
AUTHORED OF DID NOT GET OUT OF
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE.
AND ONE OF THE THINGS THAT THAT
TELLS ME IS THAT.
WE COLLECTIVELY NEED TO DO.
A STRONGER JOB -- TO VOICE WHY
THESE BILLS ARE IMPORTANT.
AND WHY THEY SHOULD CONTINUE IN
THE PATH OF A GOVERNOR'S DESK
AND GETTING SIGNED INTO LAW SO I
JUST WANTED.
TO SAY THAT WE NEED TO RALLY
AROUND -- THE ISSUES AND HAVE A
STRONGER VOICE IN SACRAMENTO SO
THAT -- THESE BILLS -- MAKE IT
TO THE GOVERNOR'S DESK AND AND
REALLY CHANGE LAW SO WITH THAT
THIS SHERMAN THANK YOU SO WHAT
WILL WE'RE GOING TO DO WE'RE
GONNA START PUBLIC COMMENT WE
HAVE ABOUT AN HOUR AND FIFTEEN
MINUTES SO WE CAN -- EXCEPT
PUBLIC PUBLIC COMMENTS SO WHAT
I'M GONNA TRY TO DO.
IT IS LIMIT YOU TO TWO MINUTES.
ARE WE WILL BE TIMING PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME.
END OF YOUR YOUR POINT OF
INTEREST OR WHO YOU'RE WITH
REPRESENTING.
AND IF THERE'S A CHANCE AGAIN AT
THE END OF THAT WE HAVE EXTRA
TIME I WOULD MORE THAN IF YOU
HAVE MORE TO SAY IT WOULD MORE
THAN BY YOU TO COME BACK UP BUT
I'M GONNA TRY SO EVERYBODY HAS A
CHANCE AT LEAST TO GET THEIR
THEIR COMMENTS.
WE'LL START WITH YOU PLEASE
STATE YOUR NAME.
HELLO ITS ROLE YES HI -- MY NAME
IS AMANDA THIS LAWN.
AND I'M HERE AS THE AS THE
INTERESTED CITIZEN WHO HAS TRIED
TO HELP.
OUR COMMUNITIES ESPECIALLY ARE
UNDER REPRESENTED -- COMMUNITIES --
I WAS GIVING IT THE THE
COMMUNITY OUTREACH -- FROM FIRE
SCENE AND THEY SAID THEY HAD
BEEN HERE THE COMMUNITY LET ME
TELL YOU THAT.
WHEN I'M LOOKING AT THIS PAGE --
THEY HAVE BEEN IN PALM DESERT
THIRTY EIGHT TIMES [INAUDIBLE]
COACHELLA.
NINE IN DEAL -- ONE TIME NO A
TIME OUR THERMAL ONE TIME --
EASES MECCA IN ALL THOSE.
YES THEY HAVE NOT BEEN
REPRESENTED NOT A SINGLE TIME
HAD THEY'VE VISITED THIS IN
THOSE AREAS.
I AS THE SUPERINTENDENT AND THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE WORKING.
I IN COACHELLA UNIFIED AND I
SAID.
IF THEY BEING TO THE HIGH SCHOOL.
IN THIS SET WE HAVE NEVER SEEN
THE SO IT IS IMPORTANT THAT YOU
GET THE FACTS.
A WHAT'S GOING ON IN THIS
COMMUNITY AND DID YOU UNDERSTAND
THAT BY HAVING AN OFFICE SO FAR.
FROM OUR COMMUNITY THAT NEEDS
THE HELP.
IT'S IS NOT BEING USED IN OUR
PEOPLE ARE GETTING FORGOTTEN.
AN IN DEPTH WHATEVER SOMETIMES
THEY THEY SAY.
IS THAT TRUE.
OKAY SO NEVER HAD THEY BEEN.
TO CITY HIGH SCHOOL.
THANK YOU Q..
THANK SPEAKER PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME HI MY NAME IS PHIL STEIN
AND MY SON WAS A STUDENT AT
DESERT SANDS UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT.
I HAVE BEEN INVOLVED IN SPECIAL
EDUCATION FOR SIXTEEN YEARS
STARTING OFF AT THE BARBARA
SINATRA CENTER WHEN HE NEEDED
ASSISTANCE.
MY MENTORS IN THE AUDIENCE I
DON'T KNOW SHALL SPEAK THIS
EVENING BUT I GOT INVOLVED IN
THE SCHOOL DISTRICT WITH A C.
PACK SPECIAL EDUCATION PARENTS
ADVISORY COMMITTEE.
AND THEN FROM THERE -- I GOT
INVOLVED IN THE LOCAL SALPA.
OF THE CHC I MOST RECENTLY AND
THE PAST PRESIDENT OF THE C. A.
C. WHICH ENCOMPASSES FROM MARINO
VALLEY ALL THE WAY UP TO PALO
VERDE SCHOOL DISTRICT IN BLACK.
I USED TO GO TO THE MEETINGS
WITH THE DIRECTORS -- HE HAD
GONE UP TO SACRAMENTO -- VARIOUS
TIMES OF LEGISLATIVE ACTION DAY
TO SPEAK -- TO THE LOT MAKERS
AND A FEEL THAT THE EDUCATION I
HAVE GAINED OVER THE SIXTEEN
YEARS.
AS BEEN IMMEASURABLE -- ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT I WOULD LIKE TO
SEE A WILL BE CANDID.
I THINK IN ANY ORGANIZATION YOU
HAVE THOSE THAT ARE ABOVE THE
BAR AND YOU HAVE THOSE THAT ARE
AT THE BAR.
HEY WE MET MISTER KURTZ MANY
YEARS AGO HE PROBABLY WILL NOT
REMEMBER BUT WE HAPPEN TO HAVE
AN INLAND REGIONAL -- CASE
WORKER BY THE NAME MADE DAMIAN
LÀ MERECE.
I CAN'T SAY ENOUGH ABOUT DAMIEN
WE WERE ORIGINALLY DENIED
SERVICES I HAD TO GO THROUGH.
THE PROCESS OF GETTING -- AND
APPEALING WE WERE ABLE TO GET
THROUGH THE APPEAL I NOW HELP
PEOPLE WITH -- AT WORK THAT TO
SPEAK OF THE SPANISH IS THE THE
PRIMARY LANGUAGE HAVEN'T GOTTEN
INVOLVED WITH PALM SPRINGS
UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT.
AND COULD CHIRLA THE PREVIOUS
THE WORKER -- ACTUALLY THE THE
DIRECTOR OF SPECIAL ED -- MISTER
GONZALEZ HAD ASKED ME TO START
TO SEE PACK HERE WITH THEM AND
WE DID THAT.
SO.
I FEEL THAT.
WE ARE INCLUDING EVERYBODY
THROUGH THE SELF VÀ.
THANK YOU THANK YOU.
NEXT BIGGER PLEASE STATE YOUR
NAME.
HI GOOD AFTERNOON MY NAME IS
SOMEBODY HELLO THIS THAT AND
FATHER ALONDRA ABOUT THIS TIME.
SHE HAS SAID IT WILL POLICY.
AND NOT I WANTED TO THANK
EVERYBODY FOR BEING HERE BECAUSE
THIS IS -- I I KNOW THIS IS
GONNA HELP A LOT OF FUN IS THAT --
THAT THEY REALLY NEED -- TO I
WANNA THANK THEM ABOUT WHEN MY
DAUGHTER WAS GONNA GET ON THE
TRANSITION FROM A HIGH SCHOOL.
SHE HAD A DREAM AND SHE WANTED
TO GO TO COLLEGE.
BUT DON THEY TOLD HER.
ON THE LAST SITE PP THAT SHE
HADN'T IN HIGH SCHOOL -- DOES
THAT WAS FROM THE ACCOUNT AND
THAT.
BECAUSE SIDE -- LIMITATIONS SHE
NEVER WAS GOING TO BE ABLE TO GO
TO COLLEGE.
SAW THEY TRANSITION HEARD TO A
PROGRAM THAT -- DOES ONE OR NINE
YEARS TO STUDY BECAUSE THEY PUT
THE HAT ON A PROGRAM THAT -- IT
WAS -- A LOTTA TEENAGERS ON THE
TRANSITION THAT THEY HAVE.
MORE SAID WHERE DISABILITIES AND
THEN SHE THE AND WHEN SHE WAS
LEAVING HIGH SCHOOL SHE WROTE.
A LETTER.
SAY IN EVERYTHING -- DOES THAT
SHE WAS DREAMING FOR HER FUTURE.
AND NOT THE NOTE THAT WAS GONNA
BE POSSIBLE ON HER SO -- SO SHE
SHE HAD A REALLY HARD TIME.
AND THEN -- WHEN SHE WAS ON THAT
PROGRAM -- THE THE TEACHER --
WHO WAS LEADING THE THE THE?
OF HER HER CLASSROOM -- SHE SHE
WAS PRETTY YOUNG I WOULD SAY AND
WITH.
OUT ENOUGH EXPERIENCE TO TO KNOW
HOW -- TO LEAD WITH.
PEOPLE ARE LIKE HERE.
AND SHE WANTED TO DO BETTER
BECAUSE SHE'S SHE'S PRETTY SMART
THINGS GOT AND AND THAT SHE WAS
HAVING A HARD TIME SHE STARTED
GETTING SEIZURES WHEN SHE WAS
THERE.
SHE NEVER HAD ONE BEFORE.
AND AND IT WAS REALLY HARD FOR
MY WIFE AND I BECAUSE IN THE
MIDDLE OF THE NIGHT SHE WILL
START GETTING SEIZURES.
AND AND READ A REALLY HARD TIME
SO I STARTED LOOKING FOR HELP ON
WE WENT OVER AND AND AND SUBMIT
AN APPLICATION -- TO TWOS ARE
ISLANDS ORIGINAL CENTER AND IT
TOOK A REALLY LONG TIME FOR THEM
TO RESPOND AND THEN FINALLY
RESPOND.
AND THAT SHE WAS ALREADY APPLIED
WHEN SHE WAS LITTLE.
DIRECTLY FROM THE HOSPITAL BUT
THEY NEVER FOLLOW UP.
SO -- I STARTED ASKING FOR HELP
AND AND AND A SERVICE
COORDINATOR -- THE SERVICE --
PROVIDED THAT THEY SHE HAD SIR
I'M GONNA HAVE TO WRAP IT UP
OKAY BUTTON.
WE'LL GET TO GET WE HAVE EXTRA
TIME AND LOVE TO YOU.
THANK YOU FOR RAISING A
WONDERFUL FATHER.
YEAH.
HI MY NAME IS KERINS TRAMITE IS
SOME A SCHOOL NURSE TO PALM
SPRINGS UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
I HAVE A DISABLED SON IN LAW
ACTUALLY DISABLED AUTISM THAT
GOES.
TO DESERT SANDS UNIFIED SCHOOL
DISTRICT BUT I AM NOT GOING TO
PUT HIM IN THE TRANSITION
PROGRAM BECAUSE IT'S VERY -- ITS
DEEDS A LOT OF WORK AND THEY
SHOULD BE GOING OUT COMMUNITY
AND I COULD PROBABLY TEACH A
MORE THAN DO THAT I'M GOING TO
BRING TO MY DISTRICT PALM
SPRINGS IT HAS A FANTASTIC.
PROGRAM SO I JUST WANNA SEE I
SAY THAT I THINK IN REGIONAL
CENTER.
WOULD BE GREAT FOR THAT
COLLABORATION IT SOUNDS
COACHELLA VALLEY SOUNDS OF THIS
SOUNDS REALLY GOOD COLLABORATING
WITH I RC BUT I THINK ALSO TO
HAVE REPRESENTATIVES THAT COULD
HELP.
ARE YOUR C. LIKE SCHOOL NURSES
LIKE ME BECAUSE I GO TO MEETINGS
NOBODY KNOWS ABOUT OUR SEE I'M
TALKING THE TEACHERS.
THE STAFF.
I KNOW THE NUMBER BY HEART SOUL
GIVEN TO THE PARENT THE PARENT
HAS I AND WHAT I SAY IN THIS MAY
BE DIFFERENT MAYBE ARE SO YOU
CAN TELL ME.
I SEE THAT THE PARENT HAS TO BE
YOU THAT CONTACTS ARE C. BUT
THEY'RE VERY NERVOUS OR LIKE
THERE'S OTHER ISSUES -- SO
THERE'S A LINK THAT NEEDS TO BE
PUT TOGETHER.
AND THEN LASTLY -- I WANT TO SAY
IT'S NOT JUST CULTURAL INS INS.
SENSITIVITY IT'S ALSO LIKE ME.
I DON'T SPEAK SPANISH BUT I'VE
HAD A VERY DIFFICULT TIME
NAVIGATING THE SYSTEM.
AND I'M AN EDUCATED PERSON I'M A
SCHOOL NURSE.
I'VE WORKED VERY HARD TO BALANCE
BOARDS OF DIRECTORS FOR SPECIAL
EDUCATION PARENT ADVISORY
COMMITTEE I'VE DONE EVERYTHING
I'VE LEARNED A LOT BUT FOR ME I
KNOW I CAN DO IT NOW BUT ALL
THESE OTHER PARENTS.
AND OTHERS OF IT BUT I WANT TO
SAY OURS ARE YOUR SEIZE COME A
LONG WAY.
I HAVE A FANTASTIC CASE WORKER
WITH MY SON AND I'VE TOLD THE
GRAMS SPECIALISTS OF I'M GONNA
RIDE RECOMMENDATION FOR HER.
MAY I HAVE COME A LONG WAY THANK
YOU.
SPEAKER.
YOUR NAME MY NAME IS LAURA
GREGOR THIS IS WHEN AT BRANDON
BROWNER WE BOTH HAVE CHILDREN
ARE ACTUALLY ADULTS IN THE ADULT
TRANSITION PROGRAM WITH DESERT
SANDS UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT --
WERE BOTH SOMEWHAT DISAPPOINTED
IN THE PROGRAM IT'S SUPPOSED TO
BE AN ADULT PROGRAM THAT TEACHES
INDEPENDENT LIVING SKILLS
VOCATIONAL SKILLS.
I SOCIALISE ATION SKILLS.
AND I'M NOT BLAMING THE TEACHERS
I COMPLETELY BLAME THE DISTRICT
THERE IN A CLASSROOM THAT
DOESN'T HAVE A KITCHEN SETTING
IT DOESN'T HAVE THE USE THAT ARE.
COOKTOP ENACT CAMPING SINK TO
CLEAN THE DISHES -- THERE ARE
STRIVING.
TO OBTAIN JOBS FOR THESE
STUDENTS TO GET JOB TRAINING
THEY'RE NOT GIVEN SUPPORT BY THE
DISTRICT FIND THESE JOBS.
THEY'RE NOT I WOULD LIKE TO SEE
A COLLABORATION BETWEEN HIM AND
REGIONAL CENTER DEPARTMENT OF
REHAB AND THE SCHOOL DISTRICT.
BECAUSE THE TEACHER SHOULDN'T
HAVE TO GO OUT AND FIND THESE
JOBS.
AND THEY DO AND NOW THE TEACHERS
ARE HAVING TO GET TERRITORIAL
ABOUT WHERE THE JOBS ARE WHICH
DOESN'T MAKE SENSE EITHER --
WHERE I'VE ALSO BEEN HEARING
RUMORS THAT THEY'RE MOVING THE
PROGRAM THERE RIGHT NOW IT'S AN
TO SCHOOL SITES IN THE DISTRICT?
SO IT'S AT THEIR INDIA TYPICAL
EDUCATION CENTERS LIKE IN YOUR
HIGH SCHOOL SUMMIT HIGH SCHOOL
AND WE LIKE THAT THEY'RE VERY
INTEGRATED WITH THE STUDENTS.
NOW THE DISTRICT IS TALKING
ABOUT PUTTING THEM IN A SEPARATE
SETTING WAY OFF IN THE BOWELS OF
INDIA AS FAR AS I'M CONCERNED --
AGAIN THERE'S NO KITCHEN THERE I
DON'T KNOW WE DON'T UNDERSTAND
WHAT THE BENEFIT OF MOVING THEM
WOULD BE.
THEY'VE THEY'RE TELLING ME THAT
IT'S GOING TO BE MORE LIKE
COLLEGE SETTING BUT IF THEY WANT
TO COLLEGE SETTING WE HAVE A
BEAUTIFUL COD CAMPUS OUT HERE
WHY CAN'T WE MOVE THEM OVER
THERE.
SO WE'RE JUST VERY DISAPPOINTED
IN THIS ADULT PROGRAM IT'S
SUPPOSED TO BE AN ADULT TRAINING
PROGRAM AND DOLE TRANSITION
PROGRAM.
AND I JUST FEEL THE TEACHERS
JUST DO NOT GET THE SUPPORT THAT
THEY NEED FROM THE DISTRICT AND
IT'S A SHAME [INAUDIBLE]
ABOUT THAT.
THE DISTRICT HAS NOT CONTACTED
APPEARANCE THEY HAVEN'T EVEN
CONTACTED THAN ADULTS I MEAN I
CHILDREN THEY'RE ADULTS.
AND THEY HAVE RIGHTS IN WE HAVE
RIGHTS THEY HAVEN'T ASKED US
ANYTHING WE'RE HEARING THROUGH
THE GRAPEVINE THAT THEY'VE
ALREADY FILLED IS STILL TO MOVE
THEM.
AND TRANSITION THE LECTURE.
SO IT AFFECTS THEIR JOB SITES IT
AFFECTS THEIR TRANSPORTATION
IT'S NOT IN THE BEST AREA THAT'S
NOT MY BIGGEST CONCERN BUT THE
TEACHERS JUST HEARING FROM THE
TEACHERS THEY DON'T WANT THIS
MOVE.
BUT THEY FEEL THEY HAVE NO
CHOICE AND THEY FEEL THEY HAVE
NO VOICE THE TEACHERS.
WHERE THE VOICE THANK YOU
[INAUDIBLE]
GOOD EVENING.
AB.
I'M TO ME DESIGNER CHAIR OF
UNITED CEREBRAL PALSY THE AN
EMPIRE AND A HIGH SCHOOL TEACHER
EIGHTEEN YEARS.
BUT I SPEAK. FOR THE HUNDREDS OF
FAMILIES WE SERVE.
WE SERVE OVER THREE HUNDRED TO A
RESPITE CARE PROGRAM AND FAR
MORE THAN FOUR HUNDRED WITH
OTHER SERVICES.
IN OUR WHAT WE WOULD REALLY LIKE
WHAT WE NEED IS AN 8% INCREASE
ACROSS THE BOARD FOR A RESPITE
WORKERS.
THEY PROVIDE SO MUCH IN THE WAY
OF SKILLS AND RELATIONSHIP
FOSTERING.
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE A WAITING LIST
OF FIFTY TO SEVENTY FIVE CLIENTS
IN NEED OF RESPITE SERVICES.
AND IS ONE WHO IS.
WHO HAS BEEN BORN WITH THAT
SERVER FALLS IN UNDERSTAND THE
CHALLENGES IN THE NEEDLE SUPPORT
SERVICES OFFER?
HOW CAN OURS -- RESPITE WORKERS
WHO LOVE WHAT THEY DO THEY LOVE
OUR KIDS AND AND HELPING OUR
FAMILIES HOW CAN THEY DO IT --
WITH WITHOUT BEING ABLE TO
SUPPORT THEIR OWN FAMILIES THEY
WANT TO CONTINUE TO PROVIDE THE
SERVICES.
AND YET THEY HARDLY HAVE A
LIVABLE WAGE HAVE TO WORK TWO
THREE JOBS IN MANY OF THE MOVE
ON TO OTHER JOBS AND HAVE TO
LEAVE OUR ORGANIZATION.
AS A RESULT OF THE LOW PAY --
YES WE HAVE A HIGH TURNOVER RATE
WE NEED WE NEED EXPERIENCED
QUALITY RESPITE WORKERS WHO WANT
TO STAY WITH US.
AND PAUSES RELATIONSHIPS FOR OUR
KIDS.
AND THIS IS.
REALLY THE LEAST WE CAN DO
CURRENTLY ARE INNOVATION STANDS
TO LOSE MORE THAN TWO HUNDRED
TWENTY EIGHT THOUSAND DOLLARS
UNDER THE CURRENT SYSTEM.
AND 90% LOSS SO THE 8% INCREASE
IS.
VERY NECESSARY WE NEED TO
STRENGTHEN OUR PROGRAMS THE LAST
THING I WANT TO SAY STORES IN
WOMEN.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR OPEN YEARS
YOU OPEN EYES YOUR OPEN MINDS IN
YOUR OPEN HEARTS AND FINALLY
REGINALD I'D LOVE TO RAID YOUR
CLOSET.
YOU LOOKING SHARP MY MAN.
HI GOOD EVENING CAN EVERYONE
HEAR ME IN THE BACK.
OKAY GOOD.
OKAY -- THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR
BEING HERE MY NAME IS STEPHANIE
VENUE NAY I'M AN ATTORNEY AND
I'M THE CLIENT'S RIGHTS ADVOCATE
FOR INLAND REGIONAL CENTER
CONSUMERS SO I'M VERY EXCITED TO
SEE SOME FAMILIAR FACES SOME
FAMILIAR I. R. C. EMPLOYEES.
VERY VERY HAPPY THAT WE CAN COME
TOGETHER.
THIS EVENING -- I'M REALLY JUST
HERE TO INTRODUCE MYSELF TO
ANYONE WHO DOESN'T KNOW ME.
I WORK FOR THE OFFICE OF CLIENTS
RIGHTS ADVOCACY WHERE A DIVISION
OF DISABILITY RIGHTS CALIFORNIA
WHERE NONPROFIT LEGAL
ORGANIZATION AND WE HELP INLAND
REGIONAL CENTER CONSUMERS.
SOME OF THE THINGS THAT I DO I
COME OUT HERE A LOT FOR OUTREACH
TRAININGS FOR AYE PP MEETINGS I
EP MEETINGS I HSS APPEALS SSI
QUESTIONS MEDI CAL.
PRETTY MUCH ANY DISABILITY TYPE
QUESTIONS THAT YOU HAVE WE CAN
BE A RESOURCE FOR YOU AND WE
WOULD LOVE TO WORK MORE WITH THE
COACHELLA VALLEY POPULATION
WHILE I'M.
I DON'T LOVE THE DRIVE BUT I
LOVE BEING OUT HERE WITH YOU AND
I LOVE TO MAKE IT FOR YOU.
SO IF YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS I
HAVE BUSINESS CARDS I'D BE HAPPY
TO SPEAK WITH YOU AND INTRODUCE
MYSELF FURTHER.
AGAIN MY NAME IS STEPHANIE.
OUR OFFICE PHONE NUMBER IN CASE
YOU HAVE ANY QUESTIONS ABOUT THE
TOPICS I JUST MENTIONED SPECIAL
EDUCATION REGIONAL CENTER
SERVICES RESPITE I HSS SSI MEDI
CAL OUR PHONE NUMBER IS.
909-383-1133. 909-383-1133.
THANK YOU.
PLEASE STATE YOUR NAME WELCOME.
HI MY NAME IS MARIA REGULAR
CUEVAS -- I HAD MULTIPLE ROLES
ALL START OFF WITH THE FIRST ONE
AS A PROFESSIONAL IN PALM
SPRINGS UNIFIED SCHOOL DISTRICT
I'M VERY INTERESTED IN THE
STATEMENT THAT MISS JOHNSON MADE
EARLIER THAT I. R. C. ATTENDS --
EYEPIECE LAST YEAR ALONE I WAS
AT SEVENTY TWO IP MEETINGS AND I
HAD ONE ATTENDANCE BY AN IOC
MEMBER VIA PHONE SOME FAIRLY
INTERESTED IN MAKING THAT
STATEMENT ACCURATE SO.
THE OTHER THING IS AS A MOTHER.
I HAVE A SON WHO WILL BE FOUR
YEARS OLD IN JULY.
AND IT WAS IT'S BEEN VERY
FRUSTRATING WITH I RC TRYING TO
GET THE SERVICE COORDINATOR TO
BE.
SENSITIVE TO MY NEEDS WE DID
HAVE TO CHANGE BECAUSE OUTSIDE
MY PORCH SHE TOLD OUR THERAPIST
THAT SHE DIDN'T UNDERSTAND WHY I
WAS FIGHTING FOR SERVICES FOR
EZEKIEL SINCE HE WASN'T GOING TO
BE A GENIUS.
NOW THOSE TYPE OF STATEMENTS
SHOULD NEVER EVER BE TOLD TO ANY
PARENT.
SHE DIDN'T TELL TO ME SHE WAS
OUTSIDE MY DOOR I SITE GUIDED
HER OUT -- MAYBE MORE CULTURAL
SENSITIVITY TRAINING FOR THOSE
INDIVIDUALS -- ALSO.
I'M I ALSO THINK THAT IT'S
IMPORTANT THAT -- THE TALK ABOUT
HOW DO WE GET SERVICES TO FAMILY
MEMBERS YOU IN THE COACHELLA
VALLEY I'M THE PATH THE FOUNDER
AND PRESIDENT OF EZEKIEL'S GET
THE BLUFF COULD TELL A VALLEY
DOWN CENTER FOUNDATION. FOR TWO
AND A HALF YEARS NOW AND SINCE
SEPTEMBER I LOOKED AT MY EMAILS
RIGHT NOW I'VE BEEN ATTEMPTING
TO BECOME VENDOR ICE FROM I RC
SO THAT WE COULD PASS OUT.
BROCHURES SPANISH AND ENGLISH
AND I'VE YET TO HAVE A RESPONSE
BACK SO I WOULD LIKE TO ALSO.
GET INFORMATION ON THAT THANK
YOU.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
MY NAME IS MARTHA -- I AM A AN
ADVOCATE TO MY CHILD OF PARENT
ADVOCATE [INAUDIBLE]
AND I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE I KNOW ON THAT AT THE
DRIVE IS KIND OF FAR.
SO THANK YOU -- LET'S SEE WHERE
DO WE START -- I KNOW I HAVE
PROBLEMS WITH.
IRC -- I HAVEN'T HEARD FROM MY
WORKER FOR ABOUT SIX MONTHS -- I
HAVE EMAILED HER -- BECAUSE
COMING TEN NINE P. IT CAN BE
SOMETIMES VERY CHALLENGING
SPECIALLY WITH THE LANGUAGE THE
EDUCATIONAL LANGUAGE -- I HAD
ASKED FOR AN ADVOCATE -- JUST TO
UNDERSTAND LIKE ALL MY
INDEPENDENT EVALUATIONS -- NEVER
HEARD FROM HER -- SO I KNOW THE
LANGUAGE MR FRAZIER LIKE I
MENTIONED TO YOU AND RIVERSIDE.
BUT HOW ABOUT OF THOSE PARENTS
SO THAT AS YOU KNOW MISTER
GARCIA YOU KNOW A LOT OF OUR
PARENTS OUR AGRICULTURAL PARENTS.
YOU KNOW THEY DON'T HAVE THE THE
KNOWLEDGE THEY DON'T HAVE.
YOU KNOW THE THE EXPERIENCE TO
DEAL WITH THE EDUCATIONAL SYSTEM --
NEVER THE LESS YOU KNOW I. R. C.
SO I CAN AGREE WITH MISS ON ACID
LONG YOU KNOW THAT.
WE DO NEED A IN IN A REGIONAL
CENTER OUT HERE -- BECAUSE A LOT
OF PARENTS CAN'T DRIVE -- FOR TO
SALMON YOU KNOW I CAN'T EVEN
AFFORD GAS MONEY TO BE AT THE
BOARD MEETINGS ALREADY ANALLY
REGIONAL.
AND SO FAR THEY HAVEN'T EVEN
PROVIDED US TRANSPORTATION FOR
THAT.
SO IT WOULD BE HELPFUL YOU KNOW
IF THEY NEED THE PARENTS TO BE
OUT THERE. TO TO PLEASE PROVIDE
TRANSPORTATION FOR US BACK AND
FORTH.
BECAUSE WE WOULD TO SOME OF US
PARENTS WE WOULD LIKE A YOU KNOW
TO BE ON THOSE BOARD MEETINGS AS
WELL -- IT IS IMPORTANT BECAUSE
AS AS PARENTS WE ALSO WANT TO
MAKE A CHANGE AND WE ALSO WANT
TO COLLABORATE WITH THEM.
SO IT WOULD BE HELPFUL AND AGAIN
YOU KNOW AS THAT AS I SAID YOU
KNOW I'M UP THAT MY KID IT IT
HAD IS FIVE YEARS OLD.
AND I'M STARTING TO TO ADVOCATE
FOR HIM.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
HELLO MY NAME IS BETTY LÀ BATH
AND I'M HERE ON BEHALF OF MY
SISTER JUNE SNIDELY.
SHE IS A RESIDENT AT DESERT COVE
ASSISTED LIVING.
SHE'S A SIXTY SEVEN YEAR OLD
WOMAN THAT IS MULTIPLE HANDICAPS
YES DAFT HAS CEREBRAL PALSY.
AND THE DEVELOPMENTALLY DELAYED.
JUNE HAD A VERY FULL LIFE FOR A
WHILE WORKING AT TESTING YOUR
VALLEY TRAINING CENTER.
AND LIVING WITH MY MOTHER -- LÀ
RATHER PASSED AWAY WE DID.
WE TOOK CARE FOR FOR ABOUT A
YEAR AND A HALF AND THEN WE
FOUND A PLACE CALLED CHAD
CALIFORNIA HOME FOR ADULTS.
DEATH.
AND SHE WENT TO LIVE THERE AND
IT IS GEARED.
TO HER PARTICULAR PROBLEMS SO
YOU KNOW EVERYBODY THERE.
WAS STAFF AND THE STAFF
EVERYBODY SIGNED TO IS VERY GOOD
AND SHE WAS STILL WORKING AND
SHE HAD SOME PHYSICAL.
ISSUES AND ENDED UP PUTTING HER
INTO I DON'T CHAIR SHE HAD
SHOULDER SURGERY.
SO UM.
CHAD.
ARCADIA CLOSED.
AND THEY WERE GOING TO RE OPEN
OUT HERE IN RIVERSIDE.
AND EVENTUALLY DEBT AFTER ABOUT
TWO YEARS OF YOU KNOW HASSLING
GETTING THEIR LICENSE RIGHT IN
THE CODING AND ALL THAT STUFF.
BUT THEY ARE NO LONGER STATE
VENDOR.
CELL JUNE IS NOW IN THIS
ASSISTED LIVING IT'S A MUCH
LARGER PLACE AND ALTHOUGH THEY
HAVE MADE SOME EFFORTS -- TO
ACCOMMODATE THE FEW DEAF PEOPLE
THAT ARE THERE.
IT'S NOT THE SAME.
AND THERE'S TWO THINGS SAID THAT.
JUNE REALLY NEEDS.
ONE AS OF LIVING PLACE THAT'S
SMALLER IT JUST HAS WITH DEAF
PEOPLE YEAH AND OUT DISABLED
PEOPLE LIKE HERSELF OR SHE FEELS
MORE COMFORTABLE.
AND ALSO BECAUSE SHE'S NOT
REALLY HAPPY WHERE SHE IS I
HAVEN'T BEEN ABLE TO FIND
ANYBODY WHO CAN -- COUNSEL HER.
BECAUSE SHE STAFF AND
DEVELOPMENT UNTIL THE LATE.
AT THERE'S JUST NOT AS A PERSON
I HAVEN'T COME ACROSS JACK.
SO I'M I'M LOOKING FOR THAT KIND
OF HELP BUT I DO WANT TO SAY
THAT REGIONAL CENTER HAS HELPED
US VERY MUCH.
AND HER OUT CASE WORKER RYAN
HALL IS ALWAYS AVAILABLE AND
VERY GOOD ABOUT HELPING.
THANK YOU THANK YOU I THINK YOU
HAVE SOME PEOPLE HERE THAT MIGHT
BE ABLE TO HELP YOU.
PLEASE TAKE YOUR NAME PLEASE.
HI MY NAME'S BARBARA TYLER.
I'M SO THRILLED THAT WE HAVE TWO
INTERPRETERS HERE TODAY.
OF SIGN LANGUAGE INTERPRETERS
THANKS -- TO ASSEMBLYMAN.
FRAZIER AND GARCIA -- I DON'T
THINK THAT YOU KNOW VERY MUCH
ABOUT THE DEAF COMMUNITY AND
FACT I THINK YOU'RE KIND OF JUST
LEARNING ABOUT ALL THE
DISABILITY SO MY RIGHT.
IT IS HERE'S A LEARNING PROCESS
FOR YOU GUYS AND I REALLY
COMMEND YOU FOR IT THANK YOU SO
MUCH FOR YOUR INTEREST IN YOUR
CARE.
SO MY BROTHER PATRICK IS AN OVER
THERE IN THE FRONT AND HE IS
STAFF PROFOUNDLY DEAF.
AND HAVE SEVERAL POLICY AND IN
THE MEANTIME IN THEM IN THE LAST
FEW YEARS HE HAD SOMETHING LIKE
SPINAL MENINGITIS WHICH HAS
CAUSED.
MORE BRAIN DAMAGE.
SO HE'S A LONG TERM CLIENT OF
REGIONAL CENTER.
AND I HAVE A LOT OF PEOPLE IN
THE DEAF COMMUNITY THEY JUST
CAN'T GET HERE.
AND I THINK THERE'S ONE OF OUR
REGIONAL CENTER -- CASE WORKERS
ERIC.
BACK THERE WHO'S FAMILIAR HE
KNOWS THAT THERE ARE QUITE A FEW.
SO.
THE THE THE CRITERIA TO TO BE A
REGIONAL CENTER CLIENT.
IS SEVERAL POLICY SEIZURES.
EPILEPSY -- INTELLECTUAL
DISABILITY.
AND PROBABLY I THINK THE OTHER
ONE IS HEALTH IMPAIRED RIGHT BUT
IT DOESN'T INCLUDE DEAFNESS.
AND IT DOESN'T INCLUDE BLINDNESS
HOWEVER.
MANY PEOPLE THAT HAVE ONE
DISABILITY.
HAVE A VISUAL HANDICAP OR DEAF
DEAFNESS HIM.
HEARING HIM.
AND SO -- I WANTED CHALLENGE
HERE BECAUSE RIGHT NOW THERE'S A
BIG PUSH. TO MAINSTREAM
EVERYBODY AND SMALL GROUP
HOUSING GET PEOPLE OUT OF
INSTITUTIONS.
HOWEVER WHEN YOU'RE DEALING WITH
THE TOUGH.
I WANT YOU TO THINK ABOUT IT
BEING COMPLETELY DIFFERENT.
I'M A TWO STAR RETIRED TEACHER
THE DEAF AND HARD OF HEARING AND
LIFELONG ADVOCATE FOR MY BROTHER
SO.
IT'S NOT LIKE THIS IS SOMETHING
NEW TO ME HOWEVER IT IS NEW TO
MOST OF THE PROFESSIONAL PEOPLE
AND EVEN EDUCATORS THAT YOU WORK
WITH.
THEY DON'T HAVE THE INSIGHT THAT
YOU GUYS HAVE.
AS PARENTS AND AND FAMILY
MEMBERS THAT LIVE WITH THIS
EVERY DAY I RECOMMEND YOU.
FOR TRYING TO LEARN ABOUT IT.
SO -- LIKE THEY WERE ARRESTED.
IS SEVEN TIMES UP.
I'LL GIVE YOU A COUPLE SENSES
BUT WE HAVE A SENSE IS I HAVE A
STATEMENT FROM THE JEFF
COMMUNITY SAYING THAT THEY
NEEDED -- INSTEAD OF BEING
MAINSTREAMED OUT WITH HEARING
THEY WANT TO BE MAINSTREAMED
WITH THEIR PEERS WITH THEIR
CULTURE WITH THEIR DEAF CULTURE.
AND WE'RE SO THRILLED TO HAVE
SOME.
VERY IMPORTANT MEMBERS OF THE
DEAF COMMUNITY IN RIVERSIDE TO
BE HERE TODAY TO EXPLAIN THAT TO
HEAR THANK YOU VERY THANK YOU SO
MUCH [INAUDIBLE]
HELLO.
HI MY NAME IS LARRY.
AND I'M HERE FOR THE FOR CHAD.
IT'S A CALIFORNIA HOME FOR ADULT
DEAF PEOPLE.
WE HAVE A SIX ROOM HOME
[INAUDIBLE]
AND STAFF.
THERE CARE GIVERS.
I SERVICES TO ADULTS WHO ALSO
HAVE -- ARE DESCRIBED BY MY DD.
PER THE RULES.
WE ALSO HAVE REVENUES RESIDENTS
WITH AUTISM.
AND OTHER RESIDENTS WHO ARE
SEVERELY -- WOULD HAVE SEVEREST
DISCIPLINE TO CEREBRAL PALSY.
WE ALSO -- USE SIGN LANGUAGE
DIRECTLY.
AND I HAVE TO SAY IS THE WORD
DIRECTLY NOT INDIRECTLY USING AN
INTERPRETER BETWEEN US.
BECAUSE WHEN YOU LOSE AN
INTERPRETER BETWEEN YOU THERE'S
A LOSS IN THE COMMUNICATION.
THE CARE GIVERS.
HAVE DIRECT COMMUNICATION
INCLUDING NURSES.
GROUNDSKEEPERS ADMINISTRATION.
ALL OF THEM USE GOT SIGN
LANGUAGE.
AND THERE'S A TREMENDOUS BENEFIT
THAT THEY RECEIVE FROM THAT
WE'RE LOOKING FOR GUIDANCE FROM
YOUR COMMITTEE. TO HELP US FIND
SOME FUNDING.
THEY WILL FIND A WAY WHERE WE
CAN ACTUALLY GIVE MORE OF THAT
KIND OF SERVICE TO MORE PEOPLE.
THAT NEED OUR SERVICE.
I WOULD APPRECIATE IT IF YOU AND
KEEP US ON YOUR RADAR.
KEEP YOUR EYE ON US AN OFFER
HELP AND GUIDANCE TO US I WOULD
APPRECIATE THAT A LOT.
LARRY WANTED TO SAY SOMETHING TO
HELLO MY NAME IS LARRY
[INAUDIBLE]
CHAD.
WHICH IS THE HOME FOR THE DEAF.
NEEDS TO KEEP GOING IN ORDER IN
TO DO THAT WE NEED FUNDING WHICH
IS BEEN A DIFFICULT THING FOR US
[INAUDIBLE]
SO FAR.
IT'S BEEN GOING ON FOR SOME
SEVENTY YEARS.
AND IS SUPPORTED.
ENTIRELY BY PRIVATE MONEY.
SO WE ARE LOOKING. FOR OTHER
SOURCES.
THAT CAN HELP US WITH FUNDING
[INAUDIBLE]
AND STABILITY.
AND SO SCA EIGHTY D..
HAS DONE A LOT OF WORK.
AND WE'RE HOPING TO LEARN A LOT
FROM.
AND WOULD LIKE FOR THEM TO COME
AND HELP US AND SEE IF THEY CAN
PROVIDE SOME OPTIONS TO US.
WHERE CAN WE WE CAN STAY STRONG?
I ARE DEAF CULTURE IS VERY
STRONG.
WE USE SIGN LANGUAGE TO
COMMUNICATE.
AND WE CANNOT HAVE MARGINALIZED
COMMUNICATION.
WE HAVE TO HAVE FULL
AND WHEN WE LOSE OUR
COMMUNICATION WITH THESE ARE
ACCESS TO THE WORLD.
SO WE NEED TO STAY TOGETHER AS A
DRAFT GROUP IS A DEAF CULTURE
THAT'S A TOUGH COMMUNITY WE
CANNOT BE ISOLATED WE CANNOT BE
ALONE.
WHEN WE ARE ALONE WE HAVE NO
COMMUNICATION IF YOU CAN IMAGINE
THAT SO WE HAVE STAFF HERE?
AT THE HOUSE THAT WE NEED TO
BERMAN MAIN.
AND WE'RE LOOKING FOR DIFFERENT
OPTIONS THAT WILL HELP US REMAIN
STABLE STABLE AND FEASIBLE.
SO THANK YOU FOR LISTENING TO US
AND OUR WORDS TODAY AND I'VE
LEARNED A LOT FROM EVERYBODY
HERE THIS EVENING THANK YOU.
HELLO MY NAME IS IN THERE --
SIERRA AND I'M JUST -- I WANT TO
THANK YOU FOR YOU GUYS COMING
OVER HERE MINOR'S INTO BE
TRANSITIONING FROM HIGH SCHOOL
TO REGIONAL CENTER.
AND I HEARD THAT YOU RAISE WERE
COMING JUST THINKING ABOUT IT OF
HAVING AN OFFICE OVER HERE I
LIVE.
IN NORTH SHORE.
I DON'T HAVE A CAR.
SOLD IT'S HARD JUST TO GO ALL
THE WAY TOOL SUMMER DO YOU KNOW.
AND YOU KNOW FOR HER
APPOINTMENTS.
SO I'M ASKING DON'T EVEN THINK
ABOUT IT DOES NOT TRIED TO YOUR
BEST TO HAVE AN OFFICE OVER HERE
IN THE VALLEY.
AND I JUST WANT TO THANK YOU.
THANK YOU.
HELLO.
MY NAME IS YOLANDA.
AND REGARDING WHAT MR DIMITRIS
WAS TALKING ABOUT.
FROM THE NINETIES LEVEL POLICY.
ABOUT THE INCREASE.
FOR EMPLOYEES THAT WORK FOR ALL
PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES.
I PERSONALLY WOULD LIKE TO TELL
YOU THAT MY HUSBAND WORKS FOR A
NONPROFIT AGENCY.
AND HE DOES NOT HAVE RACE HE HE
DOESN'T GET RACES AT THIS AGENCY.
AND NOW WE DO HAVE A CHILD WITH
AUTISM MY HUSBAND WORKS.
FROM SUN UP TO SUN SUNDOWN.
HE LEAVES HIS JOB AT THIS AGENCY
A HOSPITAL TO WORK IN THE
AFTERNOONS AFTER WORK.
SOLDIERS TO SUPPORT US.
SO -- IF YOU COULD PLEASE
CONSIDER THAT REYES FOUR DAYS --
HE'S A COACH EMPLOYEES THAT TO
SERVE DISABILITY ALL.
NEEDS PEOPLE AND US PERSONALLY
HAVE ENOUGH.
DISABLED CHILD WITH AUTISM IT'S
IT'S QUITE HARD AGAIN HE WORKS
VERY HARD AND I JUST.
HAVE TO SPEAK FOR MY HUSBAND SO
THANK YOU FOR THE OPPORTUNITY.
YOU.
GOOD EVENING THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE.
MY NAME IS LAURIE AND ROTH AND
I'M VERY INVOLVED IN THE
COMMUNITY.
I AM OUT OVER VOLUNTEER I GET
PAID FOR NOTHING.
THIS IS MY SON ANDREW HE'S
SEVERELY MULTIPLY DISABLED
MEDICALLY FRAGILE.
AND BLIND.
I AM ON THE BOARD FOR A NIGHT'S
REBEL PALSY AS A TRUSTEE.
AGAIN AGAIN NO PAYMENT FOR
ANYTHING.
AND WE'VE RECEIVED NO SERVICES.
BUT I DO THIS FOR OTHER FAMILIES.
THE REASON I GOT INVOLVED IS
BECAUSE THERE ARE SO MANY OF OUR
FAMILIES THAT DON'T HAVE
SERVICES.
I AM ALSO ON THAT.
SPECIAL EDUCATION -- SELF BY FOR
OUR COUNTY I AM A COMMUNITY
ADVISORY COMMITTEE MEMBER AS
WELL AND I'VE BEEN DOING THAT
FOR I THINK EIGHTEEN YEARS
[INAUDIBLE]
AND THE NON PROFITS AND ARE
VALLEY HAVE REALLY STEPPED UP TO
HELP WITH A LOT OF SERVICES THAT
DISAPPEARED YEARS AGO.
SO NOW.
WE'RE TRYING TO HELP OUT WHERE
WE CAN THERE ARE ONLY SO MANY
THINGS AND NONPROFITS CAN DO.
THE OTHER PART OF IT NEEDS TO
COME FROM.
OBVIOUSLY NEW VENDORS FOR
REGIONAL CENTER AND I COMPLETELY
AGREE WITH.
WE NEED NEW VENDORS WE NEED A
LOT OF THEM WE NEED THEM FOR THE
ADULT SERVICES REALLY
SPECIFICALLY BECAUSE WE HAVE SO
MANY KIDS.
THEIR TRANSITIONING INTO THOSE
ADULT SERVICES AND WE DON'T HAVE
ANY SERVICES ON THIS SIDE OF THE
VALLEY WE DON'T HAVE ANYTHING
FOR THE KIDS BUT WE HAVE
SERVICES.
BUT THE KIDS NEED.
ARE THE ADULTS NEED MORE ABILITY
TO GET INTO PROGRAMS THERE'S
JUST NOT A LOT AVAILABLE HERE.
SO WE NEED THOSE VENDORS.
WE ALSO NEED EMPLOYER INCENTIVES
SOMETHING THAT WE CAN DO TO HELP.
WITH OUR KIDS GETTING A JOB SOME
KIND OF WEIGHTS AND GIVEN AND
SENT IT TO THEM BECAUSE WE HAVE
EMPLOYERS THAT WANTED DO STUFF
BUT IT'S IT'S SOMETIMES
DIFFICULT. TO GET THEM TO REALLY
WANT TO GET OUR KIDS A JOB.
AND SO IF WE GAVE THEM SOME KIND
OF INCENTIVE THEY MIGHT ACTUALLY
HIRE MORE OF OUR KIDS WHICH IS
PART OF WHAT WE ARE TRYING TO DO
WITH THE STATE.
THE OTHER PART IS THAT.
WE HAVE MEDICAL ISSUES OUT HERE.
BECAUSE A LOT OF OUR KIDS HAVE
REALLY SEVERE MEDICAL NEEDS.
AND THERE ARE NO MEDICAL REAL
PLACES TO GO OUT HERE FOR
SPECIALISTS.
A LOT OF OUR FAMILIES GO TO
MELINDA WE GO TO CHILDREN'S LA.
PEOPLE GO TO SAN DIEGO ORANGE
COUNTY.
SO FAR THE PROBLEM IS
TRANSPORTATION. TO APPROPRIATE
MEDICAL CARE.
SO THAT'S SOMETHING ELSE TO
THINK ABOUT FOR THE FUTURE.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR BEING
HERE BECAUSE IT REALLY SHOWS A
LOT OF INITIATIVE.
FOR ME I AM VERY PROUD OF YOU
FOR COMING AND REALLY LISTENING
BECAUSE IT'S SUPER IMPORTANT FOR
US TO ALL BE TOGETHER ON THIS.
AND THAT'S THE REASON I DO SO
MUCH OF MY COMMUNITY AS A
VOLUNTEER BECAUSE IT TAKES A
VILLAGE.
AND I AM PROUD TO BE PART OF
REGIONAL CENTER I AM PART PROUD
TO BE PART OF UNITED CEREBRAL
PALSY I AM PROUD TO BE.
PART OF MY DISTRICT SPECIAL
EDUCATION PARENT ADVISORY
COMMITTEE WHICH I CO FOUNDED.
SIXTEEN YEARS.
THANK YOU THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
NICK SPEAKER PLEASE.
ARE YOU FEELING THE PASSION IN
THE ROOM.
YES.
I RENEE GRIFFIN AND I'M A PARENT
OF A SPECIAL NEEDS CHILD THOSE
ARE SOME OF MY FRIENDS HERE.
AND ALL THESE WONDERFUL PEOPLE
BEHIND THEM ARE WONDERFUL
SUPPORT PEOPLE -- FROM DESERT
ARE CAN INLAND REGIONAL I
FORTUNATELY HAVE A GOOD
EXPERIENCE WITH THEM AND
REGIONAL THANK YOU.
ADD WITH DESERT ARC AS WELL.
ACTIVE VOLUNTEER PARENT IN THE
COMMUNITY.
AND YOU WERE ABLE TO HEAR FROM
THOSE WHO CAN ADVOCATE.
I CAN'T HEAR FROM THE THOUSANDS
WHO CAN'T ADVOCATE.
BUT THERE ARE GROWING.
IF YOU COULD WITNESS THE GROWTH
FROM AND THE VALUE THAT THEY
HAVE FOUND IN THEMSELVES.
FROM ALL THE SUPPORT THAT THEY
GET FROM ALL OF THESE WONDERFUL --
ORGANIZATIONS HERE -- THERE ARE
A LOT OF US WHO VOLUNTEER ON A
ROAD.
THAT AREN'T VENDOR.
THAT WILL DO ANYTHING WE CANNOT
HOLD ACTIVITIES OR PROGRAMS FOR
OUR OUR CHILDREN WHO NEED TO
HAVE THAT.
YOU DEAR IS ONE OF THEM SHE HAS
A REALLY OUTSTANDING DOWN
SYNDROME GROUP.
I HAVE A DANCE TROUPE AND WE'RE
ALL DOING THAT.
VOLUNTARILY TO HELP OUR CHILDREN.
SO I THINK THE BOTTOM LINE IS.
MONEY MAKES THE WORLD GO AROUND.
AND SO WHERE ARE BEGGING YOU TO
PLEASE GO BACK GET THAT
FINANCING WE UNDERSTAND THERE'S
GONNA BE SOME NEW COMMUNITY
BASED INITIATIVES COMING OUT.
THESE THAT HAVE NO CHOICE BUT TO
VOTE TO COMPLY.
IN ORDER TO COMPLY THE NEEDS
MONEY.
AND IF YOU COULD HELP GET THAT
FUNDING INCREASE GET THE STAFF
THEY NEED GET THE PROGRAMS IN
PLACE.
YOU'VE GOT ONE WHICH IS
COMMUNITY GOING HERE.
GOOD EVENING GOOD EVENING I'D
JUST BRIEFLY -- MY NAME IS ROB
MORROW AND I AM A VENDOR -- THE
INLAND REGIONAL CENTER AND I
WANNA THINK THE ASSEMBLYMEMBERS
OFFICE FOR TAKING THE TIME TO
GIVE US THIS PLATFORM.
AT THIS EVENING -- IT'S GREAT TO
SEE -- SUCH A LARGE NUMBER OF
PEOPLE GATHERING TO SPEAK ABOUT
THESE VERY IMPORTANT AND NEEDS
OF THE COMMUNITY -- BRIEFLY AS A
VENDOR.
I JUST WANT TO LET YOU KNOW THAT
IT'S SO IMPORTANT TO BE ABLE.
TO AFFORD TO PAY.
A DIRECT STAFF AS A A QUALITY
LIVING WAGE.
AND UNFORTUNATELY -- THE THE
RATES HERE LOCALLY THEY'RE SUCH
A LARGE DISPARITY BETWEEN THE
RATES HERE AND I SERVE OTHER.
REGIONAL CENTERS AND IS THIS
COMMUNITY IS ACTUALLY -- NOT ANY
LESS EXPENSIVE TO SERVE SO --
I'VE I'VE TAKEN A LOOK AT THE
RACE STUDY AND NO WE APPRECIATE
ANY OPPORTUNITY TO BE ABLE TO
REIMBURSE OUR DIRECT STAFF AND
GIVE THEM ARE REALLY GOOD.
A BETTER QUALITY OF LIVING
THROUGH A DIRECT SERVICE WAGE --
SECONDLY I JUST WANTED TO TO LET
EVERYBODY HERE KNOW THAT.
I'M A VENDOR.
OF AND ALSO A FAMILY MEMBER OF A
PERSON WITH A DEVELOPMENTAL NEED.
AT DISABILITY AND MÁS WHEN
ADVOCATE SO FOR MY ADVOCATE HAD
ON JUST BRIEFLY.
AND I WANTED TO SPEAK UP JUST A
LITTLE BIT ABOUT WHAT I'VE BEEN
HEARING FROM.
CLIENTS OF MINE.
AND PEOPLE IN THE COMMUNITY IN
RELATION.
TO ACCESSIBILITY TO THE REGIONAL
CENTER -- THE DRIVE FROM HERE
DECEMBER DINO IS.
IT'S A IT'S A REALLY HEAVY LIFT
FOR FOLKS AND PEOPLE COMMONLY
REFERRED TO THAT LOCATION AS FOR
IRC BECAUSE IT'S SUCH A LARGE
BUILDING AND IT'S VERY DIFFICULT
TO GET INTO -- YOU HAVE TO HAVE
EMAIL -- YOU HAVE TO HAVE MADE A
RESERVATION IF YOU WILL BE ABLE
TO SPEAK TO SOMEBODY.
AND ON MANY OCCASIONS I'VE HAD
PARENTS TAKE THE DAY OFF WORK
FROM THE FIELDS TO BE ABLE TO
GET DOWN THERE.
GET A LIFT.
AND THEY JUST ARE PROVIDED
ACCESS SO -- IT WOULD BE GREAT
TO HAVE SOME TYPE OF
COLLABORATION WITH -- MAYBE
SOMEBODY WITH THE LOCAL SCHOOL
DISTRICT IF -- IF AN ACTUAL SITE
IS NOT -- SOMETHING IN THE IN
THE NEAR FUTURE BUT JUST AN
OPPORTUNITY TO HAVE FAMILIES BE
ABLE TO REACH OUT AND AND MEET.
THE CASE MANAGERS OVER AT THE
REGIONAL CENTER AND HAVE THAT
DIRECT ACCESS.
AS A VENDOR I'VE BEEN OUT IN THE
REGIONAL CENTER SITE AND THEY
HAVE BEEN DENIED ACCESS.
HAD I NOT BEEN ABLE TO PULL UP
MY EMAIL FROM MY CELL PHONE AND
VERIFY THAT ACTUALLY HAD AN
APPOINTMENT.
I WOULD NOT EVEN HAVE BEEN ABLE
TO PRESENT A FEW PIECES OF PAPER
THAT I WAS DROPPING OFF -- IT
WAS AN HOUR OUT OF THE WAY FROM
FROM VALLEY SO I JUST WANTED TO
LET EVERYBODY KNOW IT'S A
CONCERN FOR MANY PEOPLE IN THE
IN THE VALLEY HERE.
AND I JUST WANT TO MAKE THAT --
NO ANSWER THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME THANK.
WE DO HAVE A LITTLE BIT MORE
TIME IF THERE'S ANYBODY THAT
WOULD LIKE TO MAKE IT COME UP
PUBLIC COMMENT -- MIKE IS OPEN --
HI PHIL SIGN AGAIN AND I WOULD
LIKE TO THINK LAURIE WHO CAME UP
WITH AND SHOES SHE WAS THE
MENTOR I WAS REFERRING.
TO ALONG WITH BEING INVOLVED FOR
THE SIXTEEN YEARS I DO HAVE A
SON THAT WENT THROUGH THE
TRANSITION PROGRAM.
THE TRANSITION PROGRAM THROUGH
THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS WHICH I
UNDERSTAND HOW 2% THAT'S NOT WHY
WE'RE HERE BUT MAYBE YOU
GENTLEMEN CAN HELP WITH THE
STATE BOARD OF EDUCATION -- IT'S
ALMOST -- FOR THE MOST PART A
BABY SITTING SITUATION.
I BROUGHT UP TO THE I BROUGHT UP
THE THE THE ISSUE SEVERAL YEARS
AGO -- ABOUT HAVING THE ROOM SET
OFF FOR A STUDIO APARTMENT -- WE
UNDERSTAND THAT A BID WOULD NOT
BE PUT IN THERE BECAUSE OF THE
OF RAMIFICATIONS THAT COULD BE.
HAD WITH SPECIAL NEEDS STUDENTS
NOT NECESSARILY UNDERSTANDING
WHAT MAY BE GOING ON BUT WE
COULD HAVE SOMETHING A BOX THERE
SAYING THIS IS A BAD.
COULD HAVE THE KITCHEN COULD
HAVE THE DISHWASHER AND THE
WASHING -- NEEDS FOR LAUNDRY.
AND ONE OTHER COMMENT THE HAVE A
DISCUSSION THE OTHER EVENING AT
THIS UP -- AWARDS CEREMONY I
SPOKE TO SOON AND BLOCK WHOSE
WITH DESERT SANDS.
AND ONE OF HER CONCERNS WAS WITH
INLAND REGIONAL CENTER IS THAT
THEY ARE AM I A AT TIMES FROM
THIS IN THE VALLEY YOU'VE HEARD
MANY PARENTS SAY.
THAT THEY HAVE NOT COME TO THEIR
AYE EE PEAS.
UNFORTUNATELY I HAVE NOT
EXPERIENCED THAT BUT THAT MAY BE
ONE AREA THAT NEEDS WORK.
ALONG WITH OF ONE OTHER AREA IS
THAT PEOPLE DON'T UNDERSTAND MY
WORK WITH THE THE SOFA IN THE
SCHOOL DISTRICT IS.
EVERYBODY THINKS THAT THEY ARE
ENTITLED TO MAYBE SO MADE THEY
DON'T UNDERSTAND THAT THERE ARE
REQUIREMENTS TO GET HELP FROM IN
THE REGIONAL CENTER.
AND MAYBE WE NEED AN EDUCATION
PROGRAM WITH THAT IN THE SCHOOL
DISTRICTS OF THE UNDER SO THAT
THE CONSUMER UNDERSTANDS.
THAT THEY MAY NOT BE ELIGIBLE
INSTEAD OF HAVING TO GO THROUGH
ALL THE RED TAPE AND THEN
GETTING AN ANSWER THAT MAY NOT
BE -- THE ONE THEY WANT TO HEAR --
THERE ARE SO MANY OF THESE
SITUATIONS OF FIRST OF ALL I I I
THINK IT'S UP TO YOU THANK YOU
FOR BEING HERE SO I THINK YOU
NOW -- BUT MAYBE WE NEED TO GET
INVOLVED WITH THE WHAT YOU'RE
TRYING TO DO MR FRAZIER IS GET
INTO THE OF WITH THE THE SCHOOL.
THE THE EDUCATION DEPARTMENT SO
THAT YOU'D WORK TOGETHER YOU
WOULD HAVE THAT PARTNERSHIP --
AND WITH THEM HAVING AN
UNDERSTANDING [INAUDIBLE]
IT'S IT'S A BIG OPPORTUNITY AND
A HOPE THAT YOU WILL FINISH UP
WITH WHAT WE'VE STATED THANK YOU
[INAUDIBLE]
THANK YOU.
WELCOME AGAIN.
THANK YOU SO MUCH AND I
APPRECIATE HAVING EXTRA TIME.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU'RE FAMILIAR
WITH THE TWENTY SEVENTEEN TO
TWENTY ONE STATE PLAN.
ARE YOU HAVE YOU GUYS READ THAT
PLAN.
ARE YOU FAMILIAR WITH THE STATE
PLAN THE RESEARCH THAT WAS DONE
IN THE PLAN THAT WE'RE SUPPOSED
TO BE UNDER FOR PEOPLE WITH
DISABILITIES.
I DON'T KNOW WE HAVE I'M GONNA
TELL YOU -- ONLY ABOUT 5%.
OF THE PEOPLE WITH DISABILITIES
IN OUR STATE ARE FIVE AND UNDER.
AND YET OVER THIRTY FIVE THIRTY
SIX PROBABLY OVER 240% NOW OUR
SENIORS. SIXTY FIVE AND OLDER.
AND THEN -- PERHAPS YOU KNOW
THAT AS YOU AGE YOU START LOSING
YOUR HEARING LIKE ME.
I'M HARD OF HEARING AND YOU LOST
YEARS.
SO MOST SENIORS TO HAVE A
HEARING LOSS HOWEVER THE STATE
PLAN THAT YOU GUYS ARE UNDER.
THEY NEVER INQUIRED ANYTHING
WITH THE DEATH AND ARE DEAF
NEEDS ARE ANY INTERESTS ARE DEAF
CULTURE.
ARE VERY DIFFERENT FROM WHAT.
THE MAINSTREAM CULTURE IS NOW
THAT'S WHY I WANTED TO GET UP
HERE AND TELL YOU THAT.
AND I REALLY WOULD HOPE THAT YOU
WOULD CALL ME SO I CAN EXPLAIN
IT MORE THE SECOND THING IS
THERE'S A THERE'S A GRANT --
GOING ON NOW 440-050-000 DOLLARS
IF YOU HAVE AN INNOVATIVE
PROGRAM.
I TRIED TO GET THE GRANT.
IT'S IMPOSSIBLE TO WORK WITH THE
PEOPLE THAT ARE IN CHARGE OF THE
GRANT AND IT'S LIKE YOU ALREADY
HAVE TO HAVE A PROGRAM.
SO HERE WE HAVE A PROGRAM THAT
CAN SERVE.
MANY PEOPLE THAT HAVE MULTIPLE
DISABILITIES THEY'RE WELCOMING
OUR TURF.
JILL CENTER CLIENTS THANK GOD
WHO ELSE WELCOMES AND THE DEATH
THE STAFF IS DAMPER BRINGS DEATH.
BUT THERE'S NO WAY I CAN GET YOU
CAN GET IN TOUCH WITH THESE
PEOPLE THAT ARE GIVING THIS
GRANT SO I REALLY FEEL.
AS A TAXPAYER YOU KNOW VETERAN
FAMILY.
AND ARGUES.
THAT WE DESERVE TO HELP SOME OF
THE STATE MONEY FOR OUR PEOPLE
THERE HAVE SPECIAL NEEDS.
AND THEY NEED A SPECIAL PLACE
THAT THAT SUITS THEIR CULTURE
THANK YOU AND I STOPPED TAKING.
WE HAVE ONE MORE SPEAKER ONE
MORE.
FIRST OF ALL I REALLY LIKE TO
THANK YOU FOR BEING OUT HERE
BRINGING THIS TO THE COACHELLA
VALLEY I WAS -- THE PROUD ENOUGH
TO BE AT YOUR PRESENTATION IN
RIVERSIDE AND I THINK WE'VE GOT
A BIGGER TURNOUT.
THERE ARE MORE PEOPLE HERE THAN
IT WAS REVERSED.
CONGRATULATIONS I WANT TO THANK
YOU ALL FOR COMING OUT.
THE NEXT TIME WE DO THIS LET'S
EVERYBODY BRING ONE MORE PERSON --
WHAT I DO THINK IS THAT?
A LOT OF THE THINGS I'VE HEARD
TONIGHT -- IT IS A LACK OF
COMMUNICATION.
THERE ARE THINGS GOING ON IT YOU
KNOW I'VE HEARD THAT THE
TRANSITION PROGRAM IS A WORKING
THERE NEEDS TO BE COLLABORATION
NOBODY KNOWS ABOUT I RC.
I DON'T KNOW WHY.
THEY'RE YOU KNOW.
THEY'RE THERE -- BUT THERE'S AN
LP BEING DEVELOPED RIGHT NOW
IT'S PRETTY MUCH.
ON THE THE ROAD TO BEING
FINISHED IT'S A COLLABORATION
BETWEEN THE DEPARTMENT OF
REHABILITATION.
I RC AND THE EDUCATION SYSTEM.
ALL THE SCHOOL DISTRICTS HAVE
BEEN ON BOARD ALONG WITH
WORKFORCE DEVELOPMENT.
SO THAT IS IN ITSELF IS GONNA
PROBABLY DO SOME REALLY GOOD
STUFF. FOR ALL OF THE THE THINGS
THAT I'VE HEARD I HAD A REALLY
GOOD EXPERIENCE WITH I RC HAVE
WORKED WITH THEM.
FOR I WANT TO SAY THIRTY YEARS
[INAUDIBLE]
BUT I I THINK.
ANOTHER POINT TO BE MADE HERE IS
THAT THE BUDGET SUBCOMMITTEE
YESTERDAY DID A REALLY GOOD JOB
OF PUSHING FORWARD NOT ONLY THE
THING IS THAT WERE IN THE
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES BUDGET.
BUT ALSO THE THE PUT FORTH
MOTION. TO CARRY FORTH THAT 8%
ACROSS THE BOARD FOR ALL
SERVICES.
THE GOVERNOR DID PUT INTO HIS
BUDGET.
SOME RATE INCREASES FOR SOME OF
THE THE SPECIFIC SERVICES BUT
NOT FOR ALL.
AND THE MOTION WAS MADE AND AND
WHEN MADE IT THROUGH.
THE SUBCOMMITTEE.
GOTTA GO TO THE COMMITTEE IT'S
CUT IT GO FURTHER BECAUSE WE I
AM FROM DOES AMERICAN HE
EMPLOYEE TWO HUNDRED AND FORTY
ONE PEOPLE.
PROBABLY TWO HUNDRED OF THEM --
AND BELOW MINIMUM WAGE SO --
THANK YOU.
THANKS FOR COMING OUT.
WILL CONCLUDE WITH SOME CLOTHES
REMARKS I WANT TO THANK EVERYONE
WHO TOOK THE TIME TO BE HERE.
ON THIS -- FRIDAY EVENING.
I CAN THINK OF A HUNDRED OTHER
PLACES IT.
WOULD PROBABLY WANT TO BE
TONIGHT IN.
THE FACT THAT YOU'RE HERE
WHETHER AS A PARENT AS AN
ADVOCATE.
AS A REPRESENTATIVE OF AN
ORGANIZATION OR JUST A CITIZEN
WHO CARES ABOUT THESE ISSUES
THANK YOU -- I WANT YOU TO KNOW
THAT THIS IS EXTREMELY VALUABLE
FOR US.
VERY INFORMATIVE AND EDUCATIONAL
IN MANY WAYS TO SHEDDING LIGHT
TO THE GAPS.
THAT OF UNDERSTANDING FOR MYSELF
FOR US AS WELL AS HIGHLIGHTING
THE GAPS THAT EXIST IN OUR
COMMUNITY. FOR SERVICES.
AND PROGRAMS -- I WOULD LIKE TO
LET YOU KNOW THAT -- AS YOU KNOW
THE CONVERSATIONS WERE TAKING
PLACE WHERE.
A BRAINSTORMING ALREADY.
ON THE TYPES OF LEGISLATIVE
FIXES OR DIRECT BUDGETARY
REQUESTS THAT WE COULD
POTENTIALLY MAKE.
UP BUT WHAT HAPPENS IS.
WE NEED.
THE FOOT SOLDIERS WE NEED TO
BACK UP -- AND IF YOU CAN'T BE
IN SACRAMENTO -- THAT THE
ORGANIZATIONS THAT YOU'RE
AFFILIATED WITH THE TO HAVE A
PRESENCE THERE.
JOIN US IN THE ADVOCACY WORK THE
NEEDS TO TAKE PLACE -- WE HAVE --
SEVENTY EIGHT RATHER COLLEAGUES
IN ONE HOUSE. FORTY IN THE OTHER
AND THEN A GOVERNOR THAT WE HAVE
TO ALSO CONVINCED NOW I HAVE NO
DOUBT THAT -- THE THINGS THAT WE
TALKED ABOUT TODAY -- I HAVE NO
DOUBT THAT THEY'RE NOT -- IT'S
IMPORTANT IN THE SENSE THAT AT
MY COLLEAGUES UP THERE -- ARE
JUGGLING A WIDE ARRAY OF
PRIORITIES.
BUT IF WE COLLECTIVELY -- PUT
THESE BEFORE THEM -- I'M SURE
THAT -- THERE'S NO REASON WHY WE
CAN BE SUCCESSFUL.
IN ACHIEVING SOME OF THE
OBJECTIVES THAT WERE TALKED
ABOUT TODAY THAT THAT DON'T
REQUIRE.
A LOT OF MONEY THEY REQUIRE
CHANGING OF SOME RULES TO MAKE A
GRANT MORE ACCESSIBLE.
RIGHT THEY REQUIRE A TO A
GREATER COLLABORATIVE EFFORT
BETWEEN MAYBE THE REGIONAL
CENTER AND THE SCHOOL DISTRICT.
TO POTENTIALLY PROVIDE OF
PERMANENT PRESENCE.
HERE.
RIGHT AND THEN IN SOME INSTANCES --
MAKING SURE THAT THE PROGRAMS
THAT DO REQUIRE THE FUNDING
THOSE THAT ARE -- BRINGING GREAT
VALUE. TO THE COMMUNITY THAT WE
SUPPORT THEM AS WELL SO WE'VE
GOT.
SOME REALLY GOOD INFORMATION
TODAY TO TAKE BACK WITH US AND
START WORKING -- I WANT TO JUST
AGAIN THANK YOU FOR BEING HERE.
AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE THE
WORK THAT WENT INTO THIS BY THE
TEENS -- MISTER FRASIER'S THE
THE OFFICE.
STAFF AND ON OUR SIDE AND THEN
OF COURSE EVERYONE ELSE -- WHO
LOGISTICALLY HELP PUT THIS
TOGETHER ALL OF THE PROMISE YOU
THANK YOU FOR THE INFORMATION --
ON MY BE HAVE A YOU HAVE A NICE
EVENING AND A GOOD WEEKEND AND
THANK YOU AGAIN.
NO I JUST WANT TO INCLUDE ALSO
AND THANK EVERYONE FOR BEING
HERE -- PARTICIPATING THIS
HEARING I LOVE MEETING ALL OF
YOU TONIGHT.
AND HEARING ABOUT -- THE
CHALLENGES -- THE REASONS WERE
HERE TONIGHT IS THIS GENTLEMAN
RIGHT HERE.
WE HEARD WE WERE DOING HEARINGS
THROUGHOUT CALIFORNIA.
HE WAS INSISTENT AND I SHARE.
THE HIT THE TIME WITH HIM.
AND I WOULD AFTER WE WERE IN
RIVERSIDE AND WE SAW.
THAT THERE WERE PEOPLE THAT
COULD NOT COME FROM THE INLAND
EMPIRE TOUR -- CHILL AREA.
WE MADE PLANS TO DO SO.
AND I WANT TO THANK HIM FOR
INCLUDING US IN THIS WORLD.
I'D LIKE TO SAY GOOD NIGHT TO
YOU BUT ALSO JUST THEY'RE VERY
GRATEFUL. FOR YOU TAKING THE
TIME IN USING.
A PASSIONATE PLEAS FOR HELP WE
KNOW THAT THERE ARE.
DESPERATE NEEDS IN ALL OVER THE
SERVICE AREAS WE NEED PROVIDERS
WE NEED BETTER RATE STRUCTURES.
WE NEED TO UNDERSTAND FROM OF
STATE PERSPECTIVES THAT WE HAVE
FALLEN SHORT.
OVER DECADES OF RECOGNIZING
BETTER EARLY INVESTMENT.
IN THE SPECIAL NEEDS POPULATION
BRINGS BACK VOLUMES AND CAN
ACTUALLY SAVE MONEY.
LATER IN LIFE [INAUDIBLE]
BUT YET [INAUDIBLE]
THE POPULATION OF THE ID DEEP.
CONTINUES TO RISE.
DRAMATICALLY MATTER FACT ABOUT
THREE POINT 7% A YEAR.
MATTER FACT OVER A DECADE WE'VE
HAD ADDED AN ADDITIONAL.
HUNDRED THOUSAND INDIVIDUALS
INTO THE SYSTEM.
YOU KNOW WE HAVE MORE.
THREE HUNDRED TWENTY THOUSAND
BEING SERVICED AND WE SHOULD
EXPECT TO SEE MORE.
AND ONE OF THE INDIVIDUALS THAT
ARE LAST HEARING SAID WE'RE
ALWAYS WORKING ON THE DEFENSE
THE ADVANCE INSTEAD OF ALWAYS
JUST TRYING. TO MAINTAIN MORE
WERE AT SO THAT I TOOK TO HEART
ALSO WILL BE LOOKING FORWARD.
TO WORKING WITH YOU -- SERVICE
TEN YEARS OUT INSTEAD OF ALWAYS
JUST THIS MYOPIC VIEW ON THE
PHONE.
THE NOW.
WE'VE SEEN RECENT BUDGET
AUGMENTATIONS TO THE SYSTEM TO
MEET THE NEEDS.
BUT THEY'RE JUST TEMPORARY FIXES --
FOR LONG STANDING PROBLEMS.
I THINK WE ALL AGREE. EIGHT WE
NEED FUNDING.
AND THE ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOLDEN
OF MYSELF.
OR THE AUTHORS FOR THE BILL OF
BUDGET REQUEST FOR THE 8% BRIDGE
FUNDING FOR TWO HUNDRED AND
NINETY MILLION DOLLARS.
THE SENATE ACTUALLY APPROVED
THAT GOING FOR HIM AS IT WAS
STATED IN THE BUDGET COMMITTEE
YESTERDAY.
I'LL BE IN BUDGET ON BUDGET SUB
ONE I BELIEVE IT'S ON TUESDAY.
AND I'LL BE ADVOCATING FOR THE
SAME.
SO THAT WE CAN BRING A CALL --
COLLECTIVE AGREEMENT BY BOTH
HOUSES TO THE GOVERNOR.
IN ASKING FOR THAT TO GO FORWARD.
WE'RE NOT DONE HERE TODAY THE
FOLKS.
WE STILL WANT TO HEAR FROM YOU
ARE AN ONGOING BASIS.
AND I'D LIKE TO ENCOURAGE YOU TO
PARTICIPATE IN A SURVEY OF
FAMILIES BEING SERVICED BY THE
SYSTEM.
YOU CAN FIND A LINK TO THE
SURVEY ON THE BOTTOM OF
TONIGHT'S AGENDA.
WELL MORE AND MORE AVAILABLE ON
THE TABLE AT AT THE CHECK IN OR
FEEL FREE TO TAKE ADDITIONAL
AGENDAS WELL YOU.
AND YOU SHOULD YOU CAN SHOW ME
YOUR FRIENDS.
YOU CAN ALSO FIND A SURVEY ON
THE SELECT COMMITTEE ON
INTELLECTUAL AND DEVELOPMENTAL
DISABILITY WEBSITE AND WITH YOUR
INPUT.
WE WILL LEARN MORE ABOUT YOU AND
YOUR NEEDS.
AND WE ONLY ARE STRONGER
TOGETHER.
I WANT TO THANK YOU FOR YOUR
TIME TONIGHT AND I JUST WANT TO
TALK.
ABOUT THE ASSEMBLY
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
YESTERDAY.
WHICH FILLED HELD ITS FINAL
HEARING.
YES THREE THIS IS WHERE BILLS
WILL FINANCIAL IMPACT LIVE OR
DIE.
UNFORTUNATELY WE SUFFERED HEAVY
CASUALTIES.
AND MANY OF MY I. D. D. SPECIAL
NEEDS BILLS WILL NOT.
BE MOVING FOR THIS YEAR.
WELL THIS GREATLY SADDENS ME.
IT ONLY STRENGTHENS MY RESOLVE.
KEEP FIGHTING I PROMISE YOU YOUR
VOICES WILL BE HEARD IN
SACRAMENTO.
AND AND WITH THE STATE
LEGISLATURE.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR CONTINUED AB
ADVOCACY.
THIS MAN IS ONE OF MY HEROES.
AND I HOPE THAT WE CAN CONTINUE
TO FIGHT ON YOUR BEHALF TOGETHER.
GOOD NIGHT AND I LOOK FORWARD TO
YOUR EX THIS
[INAUDIBLE]
THAT [INAUDIBLE]
RIGHT [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH.
I DON'T I DON'T WANT THEM
[INAUDIBLE]
YEAH [INAUDIBLE]
RIGHT [INAUDIBLE]
YEAH